Hello.
Hello, Vittuber.
Hello, Ghost Game.
I'm Minto.
I'm Mint.
Hello, hello, hello.
Welcome.
Pop, pop, pop.
Do you, wait, do you hear pops?
Does this sound okay?
quite nervous um the setup for this uh is new so hopefully
it works i'm scared i'm i'm actually a little nervous but
that's okay sound okay yeah pop sarago
why scared is it display capture it's actually okay so i had
to feed the my switch to my monitor um but usually i do
instead um and so i capture usually from um or like i
usually capture or i usually play through obs but since it's
now directed to my monitor instead of playing through uh
through
what's this through
I Wait, what was I saying?
I don't remember What was I saying?
Wait, I would usually play through OBS And so the sound
comes out Like through my computer But when I put it, run it
through my monitor The sound was coming out through my
monitor And I was like, wait a second Then I won't be able
to hear the game And you guys could hear the game But I
wouldn't be able to hear the game.
And so I had to plug in another thing to my monitor.
But then I had a lot of feedback.
It was all like me.
And so I was just like, oh, how do I stop this?
And it was like two minutes before I started streaming.
And I was like, ah.
And then I was like, ah.
And then I fixed it.
Silly.
This super was sent through OBS.
know you eating mike tyson's ass thanks for the five gifted
thank you i think i saw also andre goes thank you for the 10
gifted earlier and mini scooter you're not up in the thingy
anymore but i saw you earlier i saw you thank you so much
for the 50.
thank you thank you thank you let me um i didn't know if
there was going to be something that played at the very
beginning so please let me know i think it's quiet right now
But let me know if you can hear this.
It's so quiet.
Even for me.
Demty!
Thanks for the 10 gifted!
Thank you.
Thank you there.
You can hear it?
Okay.
I can still turn it up.
But I don't want to...
I'm going to turn it down just a little bit just because I'm
scared of blowing my ears out and blowing your ears out.
So we're going to press English and we're going to see what
happens!
What if I play Italiano?
What if I...
what if i played italiano does it need to be loud no i just
want to make sure that you guys can hear it that's all okay
mama mia we can check okay so this is next um i am playing
the switch version actually i do own the 3ds version i
bought it before the before the e-shop went down but i I
thought that maybe because of how 3DS capture is and
everything, I was worried that it might be hard to see the
screens, you know, like split screen and everything.
So there's a 3DS version.
There is.
But I just bought, I was like thinking about it earlier.
I was like, I'll play the 3DS version.
Then I thought about it.
I was like, oh, wait, maybe I should play on the Switch so
you guys can, it's best on Switch for streaming.
I don't know much about the gameplay, but I heard that you
draw stuff, so hopefully it's not so bad on the Switch with
like a controller and not the stylus, but it wasn't on 3DS,
it was really on DS.
Oh, really?
I thought it was a 3DS game.
Oh, oh, oh.
But yeah, so I'm playing it if you're curious, I am playing
it on the Switch.
Auto saves.
Okay.
Yeah!
Welcome to Ghost Trip!
Oh my gosh, Saku!
Why?
Thank you for the 50!
Thank you.
Thank you so much!
Thank you!
Oh my gosh.
There's already extras.
I'm curious.
But, um, time to flex your detective skills.
Oh!
Oh, oh, oh, oh, you silly little witch.
whisper you.
I happen to be stupid.
New game.
I got a small raise.
Membo ships for everyone.
Congrats!
Chapter 1, 702 p.m.
Actually, it's 717 p.m.
Is my switch clock off?
Must have been unconscious for a while.
My head feels fuzzy.
Kind of like I'm swimming through darkness oh my gosh when i
came to there was a woman standing there a woman i don't
know at least i don't think i know her okay the text is kind
of fast oh a dashing man and then there was a man with a gun
i don't know him either well probably not anyway oh wait is
that skullface oh no he has got a big nose never oh hands up
now i'm not the kind of guy who can just stand back and
watch a poor woman get shot but i have just one little
problem oh my ass is off I'm already dead myself!
This has gotta be me.
No question about that.
After all, do you see any other dead bodies lying around
here?
Hands where I can see him.
So, sister!
I feel bad for her, sure.
But what can I do?
I'm dead!
Just as I was thinking this.
So relatable.
There is no time to be lollying around dead.
You're the only one who can save her.
Me?
But I'm dead.
What the?
The whole world just changed on me.
Oh, now I can press.
Oh, okay.
Are you sure about that, boss?
What?
What do you mean?
Look, it's you!
That's you!
Right there!
Oh my gosh!
That's you!
Point, point, point!
That's you right there!
That's you!
I'm in the game!
Welcome to the ghost world!
The land of the dead!
Oh my gosh, you came here to see me, didn't you?
If Misses a super chat, did they get ghosted?
No?
I didn't miss any, did I?
Such an undignified position?
I'm famous a voice in my head who are you no time for
introductions now you have to save her you know you can do
it all you have to do is use your powers huh me to save her
how there I am Gary there I am am am I the narrator me mint
the narrator hmm I like that no
you are dead stop sorry welcome to the ghost of world a
world covered in ghosts enjoy the world of ghosts yippee
take a look at your corpse do you see that blue flame that's
your soul and do you see that bright white spot nearby?
That's a core.
A core?
Hmm, looks like a railway crossing gate to me.
Look, the best way to understand it is just try it.
First of all, try moving your soul with the D-pad.
Can I move with...
Oh, whoa!
Oh!
That was so easy.
I'm a natural, obviously.
Congratulations!
Your soul is now possessed the crossing gate.
So what?
Now I'm a crossing gate?
Ahem.
Now then.
Use the crossing gate to save the woman.
Oh my gosh, I'm going to beat him over the head.
But how?
In a moment.
In a moment, time will start to flow normally again.
That will be your chance.
Listen, when the man pulls the trigger, the woman dies,
right?
So before that happens, you have to use your powers to
stop...
Oh gosh, is this game timed?
Oh boy.
Hey, wait a second.
I still don't know what you're talking about.
You'll see.
You'll all see.
Now then, time will start to flow again.
Oh!
Oof!
Ouch, yote.
Hold it!
How ace attorney have you?
Well played.
What just happened?
That was one of your powers.
at work.
A ghost trick!
You mean I made that crossing gate move?
That's right.
You manipulated that object with the power of the dead.
A ghost trick!
Yeah, cue the credits!
All you have to do to perform a trick like that is press A.
Now the woman's fate has changed, albeit just a little.
Yeah, she still has a gunpoint at every time.
Yes.
That's not good, isn't it?
But at least now you're starting to figure out how to use
your powers.
So I enter the ghost world with ghost.
I go, I'm, I'm ghost.
I'm gonna ghost all over the place.
Wait, let me put my hand down actually now that I think
about it.
Blasphemy, I know, but just so you guys can see a bit
better.
I'm gonna ghost all over the place.
Possess an object and then perform a trick with it, eh?
Bust in, bust in, bust in.
Now you're getting it.
Let's move on to the next step.
Try possessing a different core.
I have a guitar.
I see a guitar, then, is it?
Ahem.
Wait, no, I was just moving.
What do you want from me?
I would have preferred that giant wrecking ball.
That would solve the problem real quick, I bet.
But I guess I can't reach cores that are too far away.
It's right there.
It's not that far.
Well, I guess we'll see what you can do with that guitar.
Let's set time and motion again and find out.
Oh, am I going to fail the tutorial?
Uh, boom.
Who's there?
Ow!
Oh, nice.
Hold it.
That's gotta be some of the slowest running away I've ever
seen.
Oh, you couldn't reach for the wrecking balls too far.
Got it.
Looks like I'm gonna have to come up with something more.
Oh, my... I can possess my dead body.
What core is close enough to possess from here?
I guess all there is is me.
No time to be picky.
I've got a woman to save.
I like your attitude.
It's admirable, truly, but...
what?
If I can manipulate objects, I can manipulate my own body.
Then I ought to be able to manipulate my own corpse, right?
Well, tell you what.
Why don't you just try it and see?
Go ahead and possess your corpse.
Okay.
Alright, now we'll set time in motion.
Go ahead and try A.
Is this going to be really freaky?
Oh.
Nothing's exactly sad but true I'm afraid you can only
manipulate non-living thing um I'm non-living true clearly
corpses even though they are oh my gosh Daniel thank you for
the Akasuba hope you enjoy the game that's one of my
all-time spades much love Minto thank you corpses even if
they aren't alive anymore aren't really just ordinary things
you've got to be kidding this music is so easy to turn you
wait what about the woman what's happening to her let's take
a look shall we if you want to take a look around you can
move the screen oh move the screen oh I don't know what you
mean by that mysterious voice what is this some kind of
video game it's easy give it a try use the d-pad to move it
in any you want.
Oh, oh.
Wow.
How was that?
I love this game.
I hope you'll like it too.
Thanks.
Whenever you want to see what's going on somewhere, just
move the screen.
Okay, I got it.
Mitt, turn off the game console.
Right now, I want to see what's happening to that woman.
Of course.
Well, you know what to do then.
Move the screen and see if you can find her.
There she is.
Well, sister, this is it.
Press Alt F4.
You have to plug the controller into port 4.
Two things are looking pretty dim right now.
My eyesight and your future!
No way!
She's dead!
Oh, I didn't strum hard enough.
Ringlingling!
The graphics in this, is this a...
Is this like a remake?
Out of my way!
Oh my god!
Oh, it is a remake.
It looks so good.
Or remaster.
Yeah.
Because it was a DS game, right?
Yeah, so...
Oh my god, would someone please pick up the phone!
It's done.
On my way.
Oh, and...
Oh, whoa!
We look so cool.
Um.
What was that?
Did he bow at me?
In the end, it looks like her fate remains unchanged.
So what good are these ghost tricks of mine?
But just as I was thinking this...
Oop.
This lamp came...
Oh, my gosh.
The Pixar lamp.
No way!
I'm talking to a lamp!
Oh no, my delusions are really acting up today.
Hello there.
How are you feeling?
Not very well, I imagine.
A terrible tragedy.
What happened tonight?
Pixar real?
Ah, ignoring me, are you?
It's a little too early for you to be so stiff and cold, I'd
say.
I love lamp.
So it was you.
You were that voice in my head, right?
the dead don't have voices you see it's more oh my gosh wait
was the Pixar lamp murdered the plot thickens it's more like
my thoughts were being beamed directly into your mind that's
another little trick ghosts can do oh yeah I can do that
obviously I do that to you guys all the time anytime you
think about mint it's me beaming into your mind think about
mint think about mint just like that let me read your mind
psycho mintus it worked hello mint cosine you are cool thank
you Thanks for the super chat!
Looks like my ghost tricks didn't do much good.
Oh, rip.
Actual rip.
She still ended up just as dead as before.
How do I suddenly have mint chocolate ice in my hand?
That's true.
For now.
For now?
I still have more to teach you about the powers of the dead.
Your ghost tricks.
Who exactly are you anyway?
One of your fans.
Before I answer that, I think we should save this young
lady.
Wait, how do we do that?
Isn't it a shame to see such a pretty young woman lying here
like a discarded piece of trash?
Did I give mint all your money beamed right into my head
right now?
Thank you for the supercharge!
Thank you.
The name's Pixar.
Disney Pixar.
Well, what can I do?
She's already dead.
Is she?
Time for more ghost lessons for you, my friend.
First of all, I'll have you possess me.
Possess you, eh?
Once you've done that, I'll tell you about another one of
your powers.
I like the lighting, this.
Why am I so determined to save this woman?
After all, it's not like I know her, but I guess I'll take
the desk lamp up on his invitation anyway.
My reason is twofold.
I mean, what else do we have to do, right?
Number one, I'm not the type to leave women lying around
discarded like trash.
Good job, ghost trick.
Mr. Ghost trick.
And number two, I don't have anything else to lose at this
point.
So true.
That's how I feel.
Trick time!
Uh, what is this?
X?
That thought bubble you just pressed.
Those are your thoughts.
What you're saying to yourself in your head.
I'm thinking?
Ah!
Ow!
My thoughts, eh?
So the dead don't have voices.
Mint in my head told me to do this or she'd beat me up.
And what we think is communicated directly to one another.
So these thought bubbles are sort of a stand-in.
I think I'm starting to get it.
John Ghosttrick respects women.
Be like John.
Thank you for the super chat to you guys.
I think so too.
Just remember to always keep an eye out for thought bubbles.
Okay, good idea.
I might, I just might get some important clues from them.
Now then.
Possess me!
In order to possess me, you first have to enter the ghost
world.
And L is your ticket in.
Oh my gosh, I'm ghosting, I'm ghosting.
The best thing to do is to try it.
LA?
I guess I'll press it.
I'm ghosting!
Door.
Traffic sign.
Oh, by the way, I'll be taking a look at the middle of the
screen.
Oh, what about it?
It tells you what trick you can perform with the object
you're currently possessing.
What does that mean if I put a mint in my mouth?
Oh, if it put a mint in my mouth.
Means brush your teeth more.
Don't forget to floss.
The information is there for you to check out whenever you
need it.
So in the case of this folding cot, it looks like I can
unfold it.
And to perform a trick on the object you're possessing, you
first have to return to the land of the living.
Oh, okay.
This time, B is your ticket out of the ghost room.
Well, good luck, we're counting on you.
Who is this wheat?
Flag.
Oh.
Wow.
Take me to dinner first.
Oh, I can't reach the phone.
I'm a weak.
Wait, how do I get to the...
How do I...
Oh, so I have to figure out a way to...
Maybe if I un...
If I unfold it, maybe I can, uh...
trick there we go haha now I'm closer now I'm gonna ghost
again wait what's that up there she's getting it mmm use the
fan no I got it I got it perfectly that's funny what is
what's so funny well she's a different color My corpse and
her corpse.
There's definitely something different about the two.
There's something emanating from my corpse.
That's because...
You're dead!
Oh, I'm special.
I'm special.
What was that supposed to mean?
Not everybody who dies gets special powers, you know.
So those waves are because of my powers of the dead.
The smell of decay.
That's my...
my stench wafting the dead smell.
Anyway, congratulations.
You passed.
Well, what do you know?
What prize do I get?
A new power.
What else?
Another one?
Now let's review.
You can possess objects and manipulate them, right?
Now what do you suppose will happen if you possess a corpse?
Nothing because I already tried that, remember?
Nothing happened at all.
true you don't have the ability to manipulate a corpse but
but I think it's kind of I don't even know her and I'm
already like possessing her body like and she's I mean she's
I she's like so beautiful I just he called her sister I mean
that doesn't mean we're related right whatever it's just a
family am I possessing my sister help me step bro I'm dead
however there's There's something else you can do.
Oh, yeah?
What's that?
Why don't you try it and see?
Oh, okay.
I would like a little bit of a warning.
What I'm about to do.
I'm going ghost!
Oh, whoa.
What is it?
What's this?
ViviCourt, thanks for the five.
Gifted, thank you.
Can you hear me?
It's you guys.
wait a minute what's going on here hmm looks like she's
unconscious poor thing unconscious but she's dead I don't
know I know you don't like spicy food but any chance of a
hot ones podcast with Tara that's so funny you brought that
up Robert because I literally watched the hot ones I don't
know do you call them episodes the hot ones video with O
'Brien earlier.
I love that guy.
He's so funny.
He's so crazy.
But think back.
Remember when you died?
He just started chugging it.
Yeah, he's so unhinged.
It was the best episode.
It's so good.
If you haven't watched it, even if you don't know anything
about Conan O'Brien, I think that episode will teach you
everything you need to know about that guy.
When you came to your senses, you'd been unconscious, too.
Unconscious, eh?
Mint, please wake up.
I'm alive.
I'm not alive.
I'm awake.
Come to think of it.
The desk lamp is right.
When I came, too, I was already dead.
How long had I been asked up there for...
How long did they leave me like that?
Let's leave her like this for now.
And while she's resting, We can save her life.
Oh, sure.
You make it sound so easy.
And it is easy.
When you use your powers on a corpse, you can go back to the
past to a time four minutes before that person's dead.
Are you serious?
Back through time?
My new dream collab is Mint and Conan O'Brien.
Okay.
I'll do my best to have a collab with Conan O'Brien.
Someday.
right but there's a catch it only works on new corpses
corpses that have been dead for less than one day then why
didn't you do that on my body huh and she's still wet what
so well fuck sorry
sorry I was thinking like a fresh I was thinking like a
fresh body, you know, like, like, you know how, like, when
you, okay, when I think of like a fresh body, it's like
meaty and wet, you know what I mean?
So, girl,
she's still well within that limit.
Okay, you, okay, I know what happened.
The, the T from the limit went up, and I just, I only saw T.
I read too quickly, okay?
She's moist.
Oh no.
You've been holding out on us.
We knew you were a cute ghost maid, but we didn't know you
also had a cute time traveling ghost maid.
I don't know.
I don't know if I have that powers.
You might want to give it a try before it's too late.
But this is crazy.
None of it makes any sense.
We're talking about the powers of the dead here.
Now then, let's go, shall we?
So the time four minutes before this woman was murdered.
Hey, wait a second.
I still don't know what you're talking about.
You'll see.
Rewind time.
Ghost only haunt wet corpses.
Taking note.
Freshly moist.
Not, we can't have the decay.
You know?
Oh, and so now I'm going back in time to witness this
woman's last four minutes alive.
Not as a fuzzy, distant memory of the past, but as a very
real living present.
Four minutes before death.
Oh!
Oh my gosh!
This music is so ace attorney.
What?
Can you imagine if we, like, go back four minutes in time
and, like, some person was just, like, woohoo!
are totally unrelated across the other side of the world
they were like i just won the checkpot the lottery but
because we went back four minutes in time and we're doing
some butterfly effect for some something is changing where
the guy is gonna like drop his ticket instead and just loses
everything
that'd be so sad time paradox Wake up!
Are you okay?
What happened to you?
Oh no, he's dead!
Don't say it like it's a bad thing.
Mint mics to Kwasa collab.
I can't, he's my Oshi.
I'm too scared to collab with Oshi's.
Who are you?
Cucumber!
Welcome to membership, thank you!
I'm Skullface.
This is Brother.
Here's my business card right here.
sister my little gold oh my little golden friend you did
this you killed him didn't you instead of playing who done
it right now you ought to be more concerned about your own
fate who is she who is he why why are we here I have so many
questions who are you some sort of a hitman what do you want
with me they said we had to rub out all the last traces of
Temsic left in the country.
Temsec?
What in the world is that?
It's me.
I just do what I... How are you supposed to wipe out what
you don't even know what it is?
All I know is you've got nowhere else to run to.
Time to die, sister.
Oh.
As long as that bad boy wrecking ball.
I sure hope this wrecking ball doesn't fall on my head and
crush me.
That would be so bad.
As long as that bad boy Wrecking Ball stays right up there
where it belongs.
Look, all I want to know is who are you?
You don't know me.
And I don't know you.
This is just business.
He's so cool.
So long, sister.
Oh, nice.
Oof.
Hold it.
Who's there?
Wait, this is all that what we did before, but...
Hold it!
Shotgun?
What kind of a flashy weapon for a hitman, don't...
Oh, kind of a flashy weapon for a hitman, don't you think?
Too shy to collab with Oshi's ma'am, you did the exact thing
the other day?
I know!
And look how it turned out!
Not flashy, just thorough.
They call me near-sighted Jigo.
But I never let my prey get away.
Get this man some glasses.
Never thought about just buying a pair of glasses.
Well, sister, this is it.
Oh my god, no way.
That's her last words.
Two things are looking pretty dim right now.
My eyesight?
Oh, that's why he said his eyesight.
I don't know.
I love Nearsighted Jiggle.
And there you have it.
The last four minutes of her life.
No!
It's kind of ironic when you think about it.
A woman toyed with by fate and a man toyed with by a ghost.
But she still died.
Yes, and you can change that.
Well, they're ghost tricks!
Just like you did four minutes ago.
Possess and manipulate, eh?
Ghost and then trick.
Man, they love title dropping.
it how was that ironic it's like rain on a wedding day it's
the green wait it's the it's the Sun it's the light when
you're already late wait green light does that How does that
make any sense?
Oh, free ride when you already paid.
Doesn't they say something when you're late?
Free ride when you already paid.
It's the good advice that you just didn't take.
And who would have thought it mattered?
You can rewind these four minutes as many times as you like
too.
Oh yeah!
Oh my gosh, I'm gonna keep watching.
watching this lady die.
Yeah, trauma!
Now then, are you ready?
Yeah, let's do it.
My soul hurts with all the strong things.
Oh, okay.
All right.
Soul.
So this is four minutes ago, eh?
Fine, I get that.
What am I doing way down here?
That's just how it works.
was your gateway into the past after all so naturally your
starting point is where her corpse was this is where she
died okay i get it now my favorite show lady dies on loop
it's not it's it's basically re-zero hop in then i'm
ghosting okay i'm in oh my god the time is going down okay
good job There are only four minutes left before she dies.
You had better try and get to her as fast as you can.
There's no time to lose.
Who are you?
Oh, oh, they're already...
Oh my gosh, she's already meeting him.
Let me play!
Time is passing.
The last seconds of her life are counting down.
Looks like I better get up there fast.
That's right.
Have a look at the right side of the screen.
The right side?
Oh, yes.
The sand meter.
Okay.
The sand in the top of that timer is how much time she has
left.
Get to her quickly before all the sand is gone.
Up you go, then.
I'm going, ghost!
Oh, wait.
Why'd you make me go up?
No, I'm going this way.
Wait.
Trick.
Okay, nice.
Ghost.
Up.
Can I turn this on?
And then maybe it will blow the flag so we can go up even
higher.
Oh, uh-oh.
Wait a second.
Uh.
Turn off.
Oh, okay.
I think I have to be faster.
I think I have to...
Okay, hold on.
I think I have to turn it on.
Trick.
And then ghost.
And then go.
Okay, there we go.
And then back.
All right.
Lift me up.
And then...
Oh, no, I can't reach.
Oh, no.
Oh, wait.
Am I trapped now?
You guys, I think I...
Not backseating, but she done goofed.
I think I messed up.
Oh, oh, thank goodness.
Oh, my gosh.
done goofed wait how do i get up there then she overcooked
did i overcook
okay rank trick ghost oh this rolls okay i missed that trick
nice
open I had an idea of something.
Oh my god.
Who are you?
Some sort of a hitman?
What do you want with me?
They said that we had to...
Time is passing.
Uh-oh.
Her time is running out.
Oh my gosh, you guys.
Uh, close.
Close.
The mannequin.
To this.
But what?
what will this turn on I see I see I see I see so that will
it maybe it will catch on to the rope and then and then it
will get it will rise me up maybe there we go oh oh oh oh my
gosh so long sister just a few more steps hope I may make it
in time time is passing oh my gosh wait there's so much time
left though stop stressing me out game she's cooking so I
had the right idea earlier I know what to do oh oh you hold
it No, no, we want him to stand under the ball!
Now's your chance to change her fate!
There isn't much time left.
This is coming down to a battle of seconds!
Trick time!
Till death, wait.
Uh...
Ring the bell...
Or pedal.
Pedal to the metal.
Ring the bell.
Hmm...
He didn't like the guitar startled him before, so like,
Let's try it ringing.
What's going on here?
Near-sighted Gigo never misses, as long as the target is
within point-blank range.
Run far away!
It looks like you made it in time, just barely.
Yep, she's still alive.
Bro, get glasses for you.
And in that split second, hope was born.
Just now her fate was changed, albeit ever so slightly.
Yippee!
Oh, oh no, her leg.
Oh, you gotta be kidding me!
The bridge is up!
Uh-oh.
Trick time!
Uh, petal?
Can I...
Oh, wait, X...
You said her fate was changed.
positive girl thanks for the 10 gifted but it looks like
she's still in the same predicament I said her fate was
changed ever so slightly what is this junkyard drawbridge
right they have a moat or something hold on I'm going to
take a bite of my food
I have some chicken and rice
because I'm going to have to take care of that guy once and
for all but there isn't much time left depending on what you
do there is still the possibility of failure you're so good
at being a ghost what's your secret
a laundry list I don't want to think about failure now no of
course not but still do you ever feel like you want to start
over just tap R before time runs out although you may never
know You might learn a thing or two when time runs out too.
All right, I'll keep that in mind.
Right now, I better go after those two.
Uh...
Oh no, there was a...
There was a bubble!
Not bad.
I got so excited.
You hear something?
Uh...
No...
That'd be like crazy.
He's under it again.
Oh, yeah, he is.
We can extend the ladder.
Oh, I can't wait to get this.
Oh, my gosh.
I'm so excited for these to get, like, super complicated.
I'm not going to lie.
I came in like a wreck.
Oh!
How does it feel to save a lady's life?
I killed someone else in the process!
Oh, my God.
Now he's going to haunt me.
So the danger is gone?
Yes, it looks like the danger.
Mr. Danger, in fact, rolled away somewhere.
He got Looney Tune.
You used your powers to advert that woman's fate.
What if she is, like, a really bad person?
What if she, like, what if she, like, created a drug that's
going to turn everybody, the whole world into zombies?
um that guy was trying to prevent that and we we just we
just uh we just doomed the whole world it's bad why cute so
true though don't you know near-sighted gigo he's he's a cut
boss fight for metal gear one for the msx it does sound like
his his name does sound like that it could be though right
mint is the danger no what are you talking about so i did
all that huh you most certainly did and I knew you could do
it fate averted so I lost my life tonight and saved somebody
else's life yippee
when I came back to the present it was raining oh
my gosh am I gonna be your ghost boyfriend I had saved the
life of this stranger now sitting forlornly in the rain oh
Even as the story of my life on this planet comes to an end.
Achoo!
Bless you!
Oh no!
A stranger.
That word strikes a chord.
And a terrible truth begins to dawn on me.
She could be the bad guy?
I can't recall a thing.
Tascaru.
So cute.
Who am I?
What is this place?
And most important...
Imp...
Clearly not important if I can't even say it.
Most important of all!
Why was I killed?
I wonder that every day.
Your story isn't over yet.
Oh my gosh, wait, is this gonna end with us moving on?
And, you know, that's so sad.
Who exactly are you anyway?
Just call me Ray.
As in Ray of Light and the Darkness.
Ray, huh?
No way.
Metal Gear Ray.
No spoilers.
Yeah, this is my first time playing this game, so...
Oh, I should have written that, right?
Oh, oh, there's something really...
That I...
Here.
I came up with this idea.
If you ever see spoilers in the chat, like maybe someone
posts something that's just, like, alluding to something.
Or just a straight-up spoiler.
use smiley faces to get to push it off of the screen but So
that way I don't read it, but if I'm like cooking and I
maybe think of something don't use smiley faces Because then
I don't think I'm correct I'll be like Maybe I'm on to
something, you know what I mean?
Well, that's a new and novel idea, right?
Isn't it kind of genius?
I'm kind of a genius no No one else has ever thought of
that.
Ever.
I'm a genius, dao.
Frowning for cooking.
Ray, huh?
So you aren't going to tell me your real name?
I take it.
You haven't told me your name yet?
Or actually.
I'm Mr. Trick.
I'm Mr. Ghost Trick.
I can't remember.
Yes, I guess the memories of the newly departed tend to get
a bit confused.
Some of us get our memories back.
Others never do.
No, I'm Minto.
But if you ask me, does it really matter?
Spoiler.
Mint cute.
That's the worst spoiler of them all.
After all, there's only one path left to the dead.
And that is, to disappear.
Disappear?
Ban that guy.
When the sun rises in the morning, I'm afraid you're going
to cease to exist!
So soon?
What?
Tomorrow morning?
Hmm.
Wait a minute.
These powers of the dead.
Yes?
What about fake-out spoilers?
Spoilers that are wrong or misleading so you don't know what
spoilers in chat are real.
Um...
I understand.
I understand the intent.
But other people might get confused too.
And I'd rather...
And I, I don't know.
I don't want anything fake spoilers, you know?
So it's like...
Unless it's like overly jokie, you know?
Yeah.
So just, uh...
We'll just not do any spoilers at all.
Mint is actually Patrick Swayze.
Oh, my darling.
I long for your touch.
Pottery.
I'd like to use them to save somebody else's life.
And whose life might that be?
I don't know, grandma.
She's going to cross the street.
Doesn't realize a truck is coming.
It's meant to secretly...
Big bow.
But, er, dies off screen.
Do you even have to ask?
Mine, of course.
Oh, I see.
Two, thank you.
I'm actually a lamp.
Ray of Light Mac.
I have Light Mac!
Oh my gosh.
Metal Gear Ray of Light Mac.
But think about it this way.
If we could use ghost tricks to save ourselves, wouldn't I
have tried to save myself as well?
I mean, look at me.
I'm a desk lamp.
But also, why didn't you disappear?
Can we save the desk lamp then?
Because if the desk lamp is still here, why haven't we?
Wait, how long have they been around for?
I was only half-hearted least.
Spoiler?
Okay, no, stop.
Why a desk lamp, anyway?
I'm not really sure myself, to be honest.
But in any case, it seems we are unable to use our powers on
our own corpses.
Time to go find our little desk friend.
You're kidding!
You only exist in this world until tomorrow morning.
How do you even know that?
fact can't be changed so there's really no escaping my own
death okay desk lamp why also did you not try to save me in
the morning I'm going to cease to exist apparently there's
nothing I can do to change that but just the same I still
want to know I want to know my story the lost story of my
fate right up until the time of my death until I learn that
you won't be able to rest in peace right yeah very well i
understand how you feel you want to go and learn the truth
about your death as well you should i will but let's see how
should i go about doing that i wonder i can't even imagine
what the first step would be the first step that's easy you
start with her
The person who witnessed your death.
She should have some important clues, don't you think?
She's so cute.
Hey, you're right.
Not only that.
She might even know who I am.
Tascaru.
Yes, I'd say there's a very good possibility of that.
What was I doing here tonight in a place like this?
That woman probably knows the answer.
Hi, Minto.
Hello, hello, hello.
That's right.
Never forget that.
She is the key to everything tonight.
The key to everything?
What do you mean?
You'll know soon enough when you regain your memory.
Yeah, I'm like a baby.
I'm like a newborn baby.
I'm like a blank sheet of paper right now.
I should probably keep some sort of record of everything I
learned tonight.
That's a very good idea.
Press Z-O to view...
record of what you've learned and be sure to check it out
now and then okay memories aren't always the most reliable
things after all my court record phone book all right then i
wish you good luck trick time so if we go to our
oh me the mystery Red-headed target.
Oh no, come on.
Why would you mute her sneeze?
Ray of light.
Hunter in the dark.
He calls himself nearsighted Gigo.
But he's gone now due to an unfortunate accident.
I kind of miss him, not gonna lie.
I lost my life at a lonely spot on the outskirts of town.
What?
Yeah, an accident.
Saved her with my powers of the dead.
He taught me the secrets.
Okay.
I'm going ghost!
Shoo, shoo!
Uh...
If I trick...
I better not let her out of my sight.
And besides, I'm not the kind of guy who can just let a
woman sit sneezing in the cold rain.
I think I'll try to move closer.
Yeah, yeah.
That's what I'm trying to do, yes.
Oh, shimmy!
Shimmy, shimmy.
There we go.
Nice.
She's still sneezing.
Wait, how can I...
There she is.
She's just...
She's still sneezing in the rain.
Trying to get closer to you.
Yeah.
I'm going ghost.
Oh, we can give her the umbrella.
That's so cute.
Oh, it's a miracle.
What in the world just happened?
The crane moved all by itself, and then that big iron ball
fell all by itself.
It started raining.
Well, that's just how the weather goes.
That's just how the weather works.
It started raining all by itself, and then an umbrella came
down all by itself.
Oh my goodness.
Don't tell me I have psychokinetic powers.
Yes.
You are the chosen one.
You guys, I almost bought Arona's...
Someone was selling Arona's umbrella on Mercari.
And it was really expensive, so I didn't buy it, but I
thought about it.
I was like, I should buy this.
It's expensive, but it's cool.
A cat!
Best game...
Oh, best game ever!
Oh.
Okay.
I disrespect my body like that.
My Lupon looking ass.
But then it sold out and I was so sad.
Oh, looks like she's saying something to herself.
But unfortunately I can't hear from here.
Oh, that's no problem for a ghost like us as long as your
target's not too far away.
Just like you do with your own thought bubbles.
If you tap the thought bubbles of the living, you can listen
in on them what they're saying.
Maybe I'll just take a little listen then.
Always watch out, watch for the thought bubbles of the
living.
They might give you some important clues.
Seriously, what in the world just happened?
It's me.
Oh!
What's this?
Some kind of note.
Okay.
Uh.
I want to see that note.
I wonder what I wrote on it.
It's not just a shopping list or something.
it's not just a shopping list.
That wouldn't help.
Should I check it out?
Okay, cool.
Ech.
Examine.
I am now the note.
Did I write this note?
Maybe I should give it a read.
By beating Nearsighted Jigo, you got card key one.
Now you enter the base.
Outer YouTube and destroy Metal Gear algorithm.
So you don't remember writing it, eh?
No, I don't remember writing it, but even more
importantly...
Bing, bing, bing, bing, bing.
Uh-oh.
Don't answer it.
No, no, no, no, no, no!
Why would you do that?
Moshi, moshi.
Uh, I didn't get a chance to read the note!
Not to interrupt your train of thought, but I wonder if you
realized where this telephone call is coming from?
How would I know that?
Think back.
Before you helped to revert her fate, Didn't a telephone
call come in around at this time too?
Oh, yeah.
No!
Oh, my God.
He's so cool going down the stairs.
It's done.
I'm on my way.
No!
That telephone call!
Exactly.
In other words, at this very moment, on the other end of
this telephone line is the culprit who ordered your murder.
What?
Um, I'll take a pizza or cheese.
I recommend you possess the telephone.
Once you've done that, I'll tell you about another one of
your ghost tricks.
Oh my gosh, trick time!
I'm going ghost.
I'm possessing.
And then I saw him.
Right there on the other end of the line, I saw the face of
the man who ordered me dead!
Oh my gosh, I'm so excited.
What does he look like?
He's probably so cool.
He's probably so mysterious.
No!
I got killed by grandpa.
Is it done?
Look at this, look at this tiny guy's oversized notebook and
everything.
He's got so many pictures of himself.
Speak up, man.
Did you get her?
Oh.
Yes.
Who is this?
Oh, yes.
A thousand pardons, my dear lady.
I must have dialed the wrong number.
Ha, ha, ha.
Oh.
Trace complete.
So that's him, eh?
The man who stole my life.
We don't know that yet, though, right?
Bet the note says she did it.
Probably, right?
Hold on, I'm going to have another bite of food.
I have to, like, pick up the plate.
move it over and then put it back because i don't have much
room on my desk
mogu no this guy was after her we don't know if he was after
you
that's right so what do you think would you like to go see
him you better believe i would then you would do well to
listen to me Weak ghosts exist by possessing inanimate
objects.
However, there is one way we can move from place to place
over great distances through the phone.
The internet, oh my gosh.
Become a digital ghost.
Become a VTuber ghost.
Me.
That would be, the dead can jump from point A to point B by
moving over phone lines.
Say woo!
I've done all I can do to help you.
You'll have to do the rest yourself.
No!
No Ray!
Don't leave!
You're not coming with me?
I'm afraid not.
My powers have grown weak.
I've already used up most of my remaining strength just to
get here tonight.
But why?
Why are you here?
How do you know me?
But I had to come to ask for your help.
Always wanted to play this game, but it's on my growing
backlog so i'm happy to see you play it thanks kinky i hope
you like it me too let's have fun together my help many
mysterious things will happen in this town tonight i'm
trusting in you to get to the bottom of them and find out
the truth you're the only one who can do it i want you to
use your powers of the dead to find this truth i'm grateful
to you for everything you've done lampy but i can't promise
i'll help tomorrow morning I cease to exist that doesn't
give me a whole lot of time I need to pursue my own mystery
find out the truth about myself that's more than enough huh?
if you succeed in doing that you'll have done what I asked
anyway the two are one and the same
one and the same let's get you to 200,000 subs a minute
hashtag winning goes thank you Yeah, I'll do my best.
This desk lamp knows a whole lot more than he's telling me.
Now then.
From what I call a moment ago, you have the culprit's
telephone number.
The rest is all up to you.
Oh, bing, bing.
We're going here.
SYS 1729.
E.
Ki-mash!
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa!
Nice.
And so the story of the search for myself begins.
A story that will last one night only.
Tomorrow morning, I will cease to exist.
And I'm surprisingly okay with this fact.
I have to...
I have to find the answers before the sun comes up.
Why was I killed?
And what exactly is going on to happen...
It's going to happen in this town tonight.
We have to haunt Dr. Weird's blue cousin.
Oh, illustrations.
Cleared 702 to 731 p.m.
Music?
Four minutes before death?
Oh my gosh, look at him!
Sure, we'll save.
Save, yes.
Continue playing.
How long have I been?
An hour to get through the tutorial, guys.
Let's go!
731 p.m.
Who am I?
Why was I killed?
The one who is sure to know the answers to those questions
is the man who ordered my murder.
At the other end of the phone line is the very man who had
me killed.
Our meeting.
It's all so sudden.
Who?
Who is that massive guy on the right?
Mr. X?
I'm not sure.
really prepared for what's to come.
Me neither.
Whoa!
Hmm, yes.
If what I read in this file is true, this woman could be
quite a bedeviling bit of trouble for us.
She needs to be erased tonight.
Confound that near-sighted Jigo.
His skills are as feeble as his eyesight.
not to worry sir I have already taken the next step sir beep
beep beep oh my gosh whoa he's hacking oh my god they
covered it they have her three sizes and everything hmm yes
what I say the last thing I ever expected was to talk to the
target herself even if it was only over the telephone I must
admit to my good man it put me in quite the tizzy there for
a moment what is this place these oddly luxurious
furnishings this oddly refined music oh no the music's
diagenetic and that odd little machine I've never seen a
room like this before but one they they got her 3d debut
yeah one thing's for sure these people are assassins And
what's more?
They're blue!
Oh, the red-headed woman is another one of their targets.
Strider, welcome the membership, thank you!
That file the old man has.
Maybe it'll give me some information on my red...
My red head?
Trick time!
I'm going ghost!
What's this thing?
I can't reach it.
Dang.
Time to examine.
Girl looks like a rooster.
A very cute rooster.
Like the cutest rooster.
Seems this file contains information about that red hen.
But I can't read it when it's closed.
Oh, thank you.
Oh!
Great, Scott.
Did you see that?
The file, I say.
Wait, what voice did I have for this guy?
I can't remember.
It sounds like maybe he's British.
Wait.
Yeah, the file reared up and snapped at me, my good man.
Nearly bit my head off.
Not to worry, sir.
I've already seen to it that the target Miss...
Miss Lynn.
Is no longer a threat, sir.
Yes, my darkness.
Bah, that's not what I'm talking about, man.
Glasses out for nearsighted Jiro.
Hmm, Lynn, eh?
So that's her name, is it?
But this file.
It's like it's written in a foreign language.
Oh no, we forgot how to read.
I can't read it at all.
Might I suggest putting away the file in relaxing, sir?
Beep, peep, peep, peep, peep, peep, peep.
Oh my god, we're gonna watch V-Tubers!
Oh.
Shoo!
Whoa!
This place is so fancy.
Peep peep peep peep peep peep peep.
That's so cool.
It turns back into the chandelier.
Wow!
You have a very important job ahead of you tonight, sir.
Oh, yummy.
I'm gonna possess the grapes.
Dang it.
No war tonight, everybody.
Let's see.
Projector!
Lamp.
Let's operate this thing.
Darn.
This is a pickle?
No, those are grapes.
The phone and I got put away neatly.
The only thing I've learned is that the name is the name
Lin.
This sure is a weird room.
Travel through the...
Travel through the phone line to get here.
But where exactly is here?
And who exactly are these people?
Boo!
Oh, you like it?
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Boo, yes, boo.
Am I lagging by the way sometimes?
I can't tell.
Eagat, man.
What are you trying to give me a case of the vapors?
My apologies, sir, but I did not touch it, sir.
It appears the equipment is still malfunctioning, sir.
Bah, granted, technology is...
Granted, technology is certainly a convenient thing.
I'm smooth but our use of it is just plain off confounded
hmm yes in any case I don't wish to see the face of our
current target to my good man as you wish sir in that case
might I suggest this sir it changes to oh my gosh I was
thinking It changes to like a mint phantom stream.
Might I suggest this, sir?
Peep, peep, peep, peep, peep, opens up VTuber's stream.
Hey, that's...
Hmm, yes.
Cicil?
If all goes well with our deal tonight, we will have the
power to change the world, sir.
Yes, sir.
Yes.
It's a very important night indeed, my good man.
to make mistakes.
Sissel.
And that is why we can't afford to trust that sissel.
No, we must be very careful.
John Sissel ghost trick.
Sissel.
That must be my name.
Now that I hear it, it does sound familiar.
A deal, eh?
What could that be all about?
So what exactly was I up to, I wonder?
No, sir.
Yes, sir.
Thank you for the no, sir.
We are completely prepared for tonight, sir.
Yes.
Now all we have to do is pluck the fruit of success.
One thing's clear.
These villains seem to know me.
Infinite graves.
I wish.
reality and another thing there seems to be some kind of
connection between me and this Lin why else would our names
both come up here like this mmm going ghost I'm going lamp
can't I guess we gotta oh wait I can't reach oh curse this
tiny wispy body of mine.
Okay, let's just operate the lamp again.
Or the projector.
Where was your head, man?
I told you I don't wish to see this face.
My apology, sir.
It appears to be another malfunction, sir.
Well, get it fixed.
Man, unless you want to see me malfunction.
Certainly, sir.
I'm gonna make this guy go crazy.
These guys murdered me And now they're targeting the
redhead.
What kind of connection do we have with each other?
Spinning this painting around makes the old man head spin.
But that's about it.
Got to find the right timing and get...
Oh!
When it spins...
Oh, I can possess the painting.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, okay.
I got it.
There we go.
First try, baby.
Okay.
a love connection oh la la my apologies sir okay certainly
sir
very good these guys murdered me and now they're oh yeah
what kind of connection la la la oh what's he saying I say
this room is giving me the heebie-jeebies my good man what
with paintings spinning around and the like it's enough to
give Amanda jitters.
My apologies, sir.
The room was just completed recently, sir.
We're still trying to iron out the kinks, sir.
Yes.
I just hope that's all it is.
Ha ha.
Little do they know.
I'm causing chaos in their workplace.
Get your heads out of the gutter.
gutter.
I mean, e-gad, man.
How am I supposed to relax and enjoy my grapes?
So true.
Okay, we can operate that.
We can become fruit.
Look, we're just little fruit.
Oh no, he's gonna eat us for real.
Okay.
Let's operate this now.
Trick!
Goodbye, Fruit.
It's a miserable state of affairs when I can't even be
startled by a telephone that doesn't even ring.
Ah, e-gad!
Become Fruit.
It's even more pathetic to be startled by the same telephone
twice.
Bah!
The problem must be solved, sir.
Dismiss Lynn problems, sir.
What?
Lynn?
Hmm, yes.
You did mention taking the next step a moment ago.
Didn't you mind, good man?
You were saying.
Yes, sir.
I sent one step ahead...
Wait, one step ahead, Tango.
So we had near-sighted Jenga and now one step ahead, Tango.
So that's what he meant by being one step ahead.
A telephone...
Oh, that telephone call must be here.
reporting in sir very good very oh no is she dead oh lynn is
in danger again i'm going ghost oh here we go
this is one step ahead tango i'm at the target's apartment
now and out with it man have you taken care of her no she
isn't back yet what does she have fish is he feeding her
fish it only stands with reason oh it's a reason if the
target got here first they wouldn't call me one step ahead
now would they that's so true had her apartment he's one
step ahead exactly I don't get it but in any case man once
you've taken care of her then you'll promote me to the head
of the Hitman division.
Bah, no, man.
You're even getting one step ahead of me.
We can discuss my new salary later.
Great, Scott.
Now you're even getting one step ahead of your last one step
ahead.
This guy's so ambitious.
We love it.
We love a guy, boss.
Girl boss?
I'll get back to my job now, sir.
Confounded.
You're even hanging up all on step ahead.
Yes, girl boss, that promotion.
Yes!
What did he say, sir?
He asked me to raise his salary.
This game is so goofy.
What will you do, sir?
Maybe I'll give him some of nearsighted g- oh gigo!
Oh, a dango and gigo.
I called him uh, I called him uh, I called him jango, I
think.
Gigo, gigo, gigo.
That makes sense.
G go, G go, 10 go.
I go, we go, G go, 10 go.
One go, two go, blue go, red go.
Near-sighted ahead, Jankum.
Lynn, I can't lose her.
She's my only lead if I ever hope to solve the mystery of
me.
Ah, here we go.
Oh my gosh, we're going to her apartment.
How exciting.
Jigoku and Tengoku?
Oh, that's so...
He did not kill the dog.
Did he kill the dog?
No!
The telephone line guided me to Lin's apartment.
Unfortunately, Lynn isn't here yet, but unfortunately, the
Hitman is.
Oh my gosh, she's got, like, giant, giant, like, what are
those cheesy rings and a bowl?
And there are a couple of other unfortunate little
developments waiting for me, it seems.
No, oh, who is that?
Oh my gosh, what?
Hmm, it looks like there's an unlikely, unlucky little lady
here tonight.
lady.
I didn't even unlock here, little doggy.
No, no, no, no, no.
A poor brave little warrior.
We'll save him.
We'll save him, though.
He must have been trying to defend his mistress.
No.
Not the dog.
If Lynn came home now, I have to do something about the
situation and fast.
Can we go back in time and save the dog?
I think we can.
Where am I?
And more to the point, who am I?
Oh, wait, the dog can talk?
Who am I?
Well, are you talking to me?
Of course.
Do you see anybody else around here?
If I remember right, the dead don't have voices.
Their thoughts reach the other person directly.
Oof, oof, roof.
explains why this dog is talking to me right now.
This is your mistress's apartment, and you are presumably
the little doggy who died here.
Died?
So I'm dead, woof?
Let's see.
The dead lose their memories.
They even forget what they look like.
And so that's what this blue flame shape is all about.
Oh, woof!
There's no time to lose, woof!
Miss Camilla!
My Miss Camilla is in trouble woof oh you mean you remember
you know who you are oh that's right I'm Missa Missa nice to
meet you I'm a Pomeranian woof Wow I guess now I know it's
possible for the dead to regain their memories Missa thanks
to this little doggy.
Miss Camilla!
My Miss Camilla is in trouble and I vowed to devote my life
to protecting her, wolf!
Oh my gosh, pretty!
Thank you for the 50 gifted!
Thank you so much!
Thank you!
But I died before I could rescue her.
How could I let her down like this, wolf?
So you're more worried about your mistress' safety than your
own death, eh?
I like your moxie, little doggy.
Looks like it's time to go back to four minutes before this
little guy's death.
This time to save...
Time to save this...
Wait.
Time...
That's not me, right?
Time to save...
This...
His...
Life.
Time to save this his life!
Updated the phone book.
Rewind.
And I saw that I could open up the door of the door we
possessed right before possessing the Maison de Amida.
Let's see.
First of all, I'd better see what I can find out before your
death, little guy.
Excuse me, but...
Where exactly are we?
Huh?
You follow me?
I followed you.
You brought me with you.
One or the other.
Hmm.
It looks like the dead can move around together.
This is the land of four minutes before your death Really
we're really here?
So that means you're going to save Miss Camilla, doesn't it?
Missile both in ghost trick and an ace attorney is based on
Shue Takumi's Shiba.
He passed away a few years ago.
Oh no Aww So the dog was name is Nikita or Stinger?
Looks like a Nikita to me, right?
Missile
I mean, we just traveled through time, and not especially.
I mean, Miss Camilla can walk around on two legs, but I
can't do that.
So if she can do that, then it's not so strange that you can
walk backwards through time.
So that's the way your mind works, eh?
I guess that's reasonable enough.
Sorry.
Come on, come on, let's get started.
Oof.
First, we watch your last four minutes unfold.
Then we use what we learn to save Camilla.
Just like when I saved Lynn at the junkyard.
If we watch closely, we ought to be able to get a few leads.
Keep your eyes open.
Of course.
Woof!
Leave it to me to sniff out of you clues.
Okay.
Oh, she's under the couch for some reason.
She's so cute.
Yippee!
I found the remote!
Oh, that is so...
How are you able to watch anything?
is doing what the gay oh who the heck is that oh my shut
that mud up
no missile you're not supposed to bark the art here
particularly reminds me of poppin the lady next door is
crappier than ever tonight If it barks again.
Oh, knock this wall down.
Kind of Mega Man.
Maybe very pop and mention.
Lady hate.
Yeah.
Yeah, who's going to pay?
I don't think knocking the wall down is going to solve your
problems.
I think it's going to make it even worse.
Actually, Ace Attorney Missile came before, then Shue
Takumi's Missile, then Ghost Trick Missile.
Whoever sent the super chat before, you got, um, actually.
You don't want her to knock the wall down, do you, boy?
Why do you like to bark so much anyway?
Um, actually.
You sure are cute.
But just don't get us killed, okay?
Ish.
Darn.
I really wanted to watch TV, too.
Hey, I know.
I'll listen to music.
Oh, no.
That's why she probably couldn't hear the guy who, uh...
Okay, so we're gonna have to...
Oh.
That was close.
We're gonna have to knock her music into the water so that
she can't hear.
Or so she can't listen.
Because otherwise she's gonna miss the guy.
I'm in the mood for donuts tonight.
Look at the tail.
It's just like her.
It's like her hair.
Oh, no, no.
What?
Oh, my gosh.
Do we have a rat infestation?
Uh-oh.
He's gonna bark.
Oh, no!
I'll knock this wall down.
Oh, my God.
This is so bad.
Remy.
Oh.
Why?
Why has he got, like, a scope like...
I don't really like it when jobs outside the original scope
crop up.
I have to put it down as a separate charge, and accounting
never likes that.
Oh my god, point blank.
But I guess it can't be helped.
Sorry, kid.
I'm...
Did it show anything?
I closed my...
Did it show anything because I closed my eyes.
I couldn't watch.
It faded to white?
Okay, good.
Oh my god.
So that's the whole dramatic story of what happened four
minutes before you died.
Wow, look at that.
I'm dead.
Kind of shocked to tell the truth.
Okay, let's get started on saving her.
One.
Let's see.
How are we going to do this?
Seems to me the easiest way would be for you to take a big
bite out of that man's leg.
I don't think I could do that.
Whenever somebody I don't know comes around, all I wanna say
to them is, welcome.
I can't help it.
This dog is so cute.
What a good boy.
Who's that good boy?
Okay, then I guess the only thing we can do is get the
little lady to help herself somehow.
I don't think she could do that.
Did you notice her putting those red things on her head?
Oh, you mean the headphones.
Whenever she puts those red things on, that's it.
I can call her name until my throat is sore.
hears me that is very dangerous I feel so much anxiety if I
because you know how like most earbuds nowadays have what's
the word like the you can do noise cancelling and then you
can do where you have the the it's it's where you can hear
the the world as well
Transparency make a transparent mode.
Hmm pass-through something like that I guess it depends on
what earbuds you have ambient mode.
I think mine is called ambient mode But yeah, if I'm not in
ambient mode, I get so much anxiety Because it's like I only
have I only do noise cancelling on planes But girl didn't
even hear a gunshot.
I know that's what I'm saying To be perfectly honest.
I hate those red things Hmm You're right.
With those headphones on, our little lady doesn't even hear
the sound of the intruder's gun.
So maybe that's our first lead.
Now we know we have to do something.
Oh, we have to do something about that.
Yes, yes.
Oh, I'm scared.
I'm nervous.
Trick time.
I'm going ghost.
All right.
Open the door.
Oh, we can extend it.
Extend.
Dang.
it doesn't uh retract maybe oh so close you almost knocked
those red things down i think you're on to something there
if we drop them in the fish tank z i said earlier we gotta
drop them in the fish tank hmm camilla won't be able to use
them anymore but if we drop them in the fish tank miss
camilla will get a scolding from miss lynn all you have to
do is pretend it was your fault that's the way of the
honorable warrior okay 180 i Are you calling me stupid?
180 IQ?
Like a genome soldier?
Are you calling me dumb?
180 is good though.
I don't know.
I played Metal Gear.
You've obviously never seen Miss Lynn when she gets mad.
I think she'll understand if, uh, let's see.
We have a telephone.
What happens if I open this?
I think the dog is barking.
Hmm.
There's nothing else I can reach though.
If I extend it again...
Uh...
Oh wait, okay, I saw the check mark.
Um, I see.
Hmm.
Is there any...
Can I dial?
Oh, that's funny.
Wait, what's wrong?
This telephone doesn't seem to be working right now.
Usually the telephone line glows red, but it's dark right
now.
Looks like I can't use the telephone line in the four
minutes before death row.
Okay.
Eh.
Hmm.
Hold fast forward through already read dialogue, by the way.
Oh, thank you.
You literally called yourself stupid at the start of the
stream?
Tehepero?
There's stuff over there!
I want to see it.
Hold on.
This is where she says you're not supposed to bark.
Um...
Do I just keep trying?
No.
It's not gonna work.
Hmm.
I can't get close to anything.
This is where she says...
Oh, no, I didn't mean to!
I pressed X instead of Y.
How do I fast forward?
Oh, there we go.
Nice.
See what she says?
Well, maybe we have to time it when she listens to the
music, right?
So...
Maybe when she grabs it, we extend it.
We knock it out of her hands.
Time is passing.
Nice.
There we go.
Oh, no!
Darn!
How did I manage to do that?
Lynn just bought those headphones, too.
Wrecked.
Whoopsie.
How about if we tell her you did it, Missile?
Everybody 07 for this honorable warrior taking the fall.
Missile.
soul your your fall will not be in vain
oof oof time now I can't even listen to music either I think
the gods are playing tricks on me tonight forgive me miss
Camilla I'm only doing it to save you
mmm so what now you think you're one of the gods, eh?
I'm a god.
I'm a god!
Huh?
No.
Never mind that.
The important thing is we managed to change the situation.
Sorry, I'm, like, chewing.
That's true.
At least we can now use the little lady's ears to help us.
DJ Cat, welcome to membership.
Thank you!
Oh, we got more time.
mood for donuts tonight
hello the question is what do we do now yeah meo jam welcome
to membership thank you unless we do something more the
outcome will still be the same if only I had a big strong
teeth and an aggressive spirit the god of maids doesn't it
seem like we can stop the hidden man from coming in so yeah
Um, do you not lock your doors?
I have an idea.
Why don't we hide Miss Camilla?
Hide, huh?
That sounds just like the kind of idea a little doggy would
come up with.
Are you making fun of me?
But where could a little lady hide in this room?
We have the Christmas tree, we have under the couch.
I think I might have just the place.
But there's just one little problem.
How to get Miss Camilla in there, right?
Oh, sorry.
My friend Emody is playing Mario.
Exactly.
If I could possess Camilla herself, the answer would be
easy.
But I can't do that, so I guess the only way to do it is to
lead her here.
Now, what can I do using the objects in this room?
I think I'll try out various things and see what I can come
up with.
And I'll be here watching, cheering you on.
Okay, now we can possess this.
We can rock the bowl.
Let's rock the bull.
Oh, wee.
Time is passing.
I'm sorry, little mouse.
Ah, sorry.
I just unplugged my controller.
There we go.
Because I thought it was...
I was charging it while I was playing.
Okay.
Sorry.
Stop the dog from barking, though, right?
Move!
Shhh, shh, shh!
If you bark like that, you'll make the lady next door start
howling!
If you keep this up, that wall is going to come down on our
heads before we know it!
But you'll protect me from anything if anything bad happens,
right, Missal?
Of course I will!
That's quite a big promise for a little fellow.
The poor little guy's up against some formidable opponents.
The man in black and the woman in purple.
What about the... Wait, the rat?
Maybe she needs to see the rat and hide from it because
she's scared, right?
We might have to redo.
I might have to redo.
Maybe she gets scared of the rat.
Time is passing.
Why do you always give your mistress so much trouble?
Guess I'm truly embarrassed by my own behavior.
But when that little guy starts squeaking, it gets me all in
an uproar.
And when I bark, Miss Camilla always comes over and gives me
a nice hug.
Hmm, we might be able to take advantage of that for...
Take advantage of that piece of information.
Okay.
Huh?
How?
Wherever the donut falls, the rat shows up to check it out.
And then you go and bark at the rat.
And then our little lady comes to you and to quiet you down.
That's just the way things work, I'm afraid.
So in other words, the donut can be the bait that will lead
the little lady to where we want her.
Okay.
What's that up there?
Oh my god.
Sorry.
Shh.
Oh my god.
Missile.
Shh.
You're stressing me out.
I think we're...
Let's try moving again.
Oh no, it goes back to the other spot.
Where'd the donuts go?
It's written into your jeans, the destiny to bark.
Over here.
There's no way I can get over in these spots yet.
So let's drop another donut.
She's reaching for the donuts again.
So cute.
Okay, you rock.
Oh, it didn't work this time.
Damn, she is downing those donuts.
I can't make another donut fall.
What do we do now?
Without the donut, the squeaking guy won't come in.
I won't bark.
Looks like the only...
Like, only one donut will fall.
But the donut's the only bait that will lead the little lady
to where we want her.
Maybe I should rethink my plan of attack.
Oh.
I mean, this plays, and we can make her bark, right?
Oh my god.
Might have to redo, yeah.
But, let's...
It's said that maybe we should sometimes wait until the end.
So let's not just stop right now, I think.
The spinning Santa.
Can I reach it?
Oh, I can, I can!
Nice.
Oh, but I can't reach any of this.
Oh, oh, rotate faster.
Wee!
Yeah!
Oh, my God.
Oh, I'm so close.
Nice.
Latch.
What's this?
Oh.
Oh, time is passing.
Oh, gosh, I'm scared.
Oh.
Okay, there we go.
Okay.
What's this?
Rock the painting?
That didn't do anything?
Okay.
Um.
Maybe let's rotate slower.
The painting rocked.
Yes.
Okay, nice.
we can get to the lamp.
We can get to the door.
This will open it and do that.
And then we have a little ball for the dog, right?
You sent that thing flying.
I like to tidy up by shoving eyesores under the sofa.
How come you're looking at me when you say that?
Hey, wait a minute.
Under the sofa, eh?
Yes, yes.
That might be a spot where the hitman wouldn't look.
Come to think of it.
time why trying to catch me you're a naughty little doggy
aren't you you naughty little dog you which makes him a bad
hitman he's not mere sighted he is one step ahead okay he
doesn't know so my new plan is to hide the little lady under
the sofa the only problem is how do I lead her under there
yes Very good question indeed.
We don't have much time left.
Shoo, okay.
And then we knock this music box down, but I don't think
it's doing much.
Oh, I think we have to act it.
Maybe the dog is asleep, so if we play the ornament, the dog
might notice the ball underneath, right?
Shut that mud up, shut that mud up.
Does he notice it?
No, he didn't.
He fell back asleep.
Oh my god, no way.
Three!
What do you mean three?
Looks like I'm down to a few more seconds.
Miss Camilla!
We have to do something!
We just have to!
Now now, getting worked up isn't going to help.
We're down to the wire here.
Do we have enough time to do something to change her fate?
Or is it time to use another one of my ghost tricks?
Another ghost trick.
What is it?
We could rewind time and start all over again from four
minutes ago.
Whatever we do, we better hurry!
Oh, geez.
Um, how I can't I possess the ball?
I don't think there's anything else I can do.
Like, I can move the cart.
Would that do anything?
Okay, worth a shot, right?
Move the cart.
Meow.
Oh, my God, too!
Oh!
it didn't change anything um it's fan tover it's mint over
oh make the donut fall if we can't there's only one wait
okay i have a question so if she dies i can still like i can
still rewind i just um i can rewind at any time but even if
she dies i can rewind still right
Yeah, you can silver star?
Okay, okay.
The game deletes your save.
Okay.
Rocket!
Oh my god.
I don't think there's anything I can do.
I'm gonna open the door!
Make that rat go flying!
I think we're done, Zo.
Danzo.
Uh.
Oh my god.
Why don't you lock your door?
Bite him!
Oh my god.
Listen up, little girl.
I'll make you a deal.
If you promise to keep quiet, I'll let you live.
For now, anyway.
What a shame.
But I guess this brave little fellow refuses to accept...
He's a dog!
Missile!
No!
Okay.
Oh!
Time's up.
Doesn't seem like I can stop the intruder from coming in.
Guess this little doggy doesn't have much fighting power.
People often tell me my name doesn't suit me.
I guess the only thing to do is hide our little lady
someplace where the hitman can't see her.
Okay, let's rewind time.
After fate change.
Wait.
Fate change what?
Yeah, yeah.
We'll start from the fate change.
didn't have anything to do with the donuts.
Then we don't have to wait for the headphones again.
Okay.
We probably shouldn't let that guy go flying.
We probably shouldn't let that little guy go flying.
But I think we should move the cart over here.
And I also Don't want to exactly wait.
Or I want to have the ball under there as well, I think.
I think it would help to have the ball under there too.
Oh, wait.
There we go.
Okay.
I still am curious about this music box, though.
Rotate faster.
Okay.
Okay, let's open that.
Oh, my God.
Thank you for the 50 gifted wandering taco.
Thank you.
Oh, oh, wait.
Oh, no, I was right.
Dang it.
Oh, okay.
Never mind.
Oh, my gosh.
Okay, there we go.
Okay.
I don't think there's anything we can do with the painting
that I know of.
I also can't reach it.
oh wait oh shoot i just realized we ah we have to do the
star first
sometimes the going back and forth makes me like a little or
like the going ghost mode and not ghost mode makes me a
little okay uh now the star
yeah a little motion sick yeah oh there we go when it starts
going fast it can hurt the eyes yeah just a little what does
it say here if you bark like that how could anybody enjoy
the pretty melody and your poor mistress has to get up and
quiet you down every time yes i oh look at that one of the
ornaments fell off the tree not interested in things like
that i graduated from playing with balls a long time ago you
should try graduating from meatless barking too
Sorry, that's one thing I could never give up.
Okay, here.
Here, here.
I don't think it hurts to have this done, you know, to have
it there, I think.
I don't think it hurts to have it under the couch.
That's what I'm in.
Okay, now, rock.
Wait, it goes that way?
Oh my gosh, it's a little pink mouse!
Uh, oh, oh, and then I...
Okay, hold on.
Ugh!
Do I fling her?
Do I fling...
Wait, which way does it open?
I think I fling the mouse this way, right?
Fuha!
Okay.
The yeet school.
Oh, what are you doing under you, you silly boy?
First dono currently going through exams.
I love watching along while studying.
Thanks for the fun streams.
Thanks, Rainy, girl.
Good luck with yours.
Oh, exams.
I almost said your streams.
Good luck with your exams.
I'm taking another bite.
Oh, my little missile.
You're always doing the cutest things.
Okay.
Oh!
Nobody's here, right?
Oh my god.
This guy is deaf.
He can't hear the dog going, My prey is bound to come home
sometime.
Might as well make myself comfortable in the meantime.
Meanwhile, you better not eat a donut.
Don't do it!
There, our little lady's fate has been averted.
Let's go!
We got it.
It has?
A poor thing is still curled up in a ball and shaking with
fear.
Well, yeah, that's true.
But that's not so bad.
In the scheme of things, I'd say she's just fine.
And look, you're not dead.
Oh, you're right.
We did it.
We did it, didn't we?
Well, to be precise, you're the one who did it huh me I
saved miss Camilla yep you're the one who led her under the
sofa right you protected your mistress I can attest to that
oh oh thank you fate averted can I ask a question sure what
is it what exactly are those strange powers of yours hit man
I'm going to take this donut and eat it.
Stop ancient meme.
Oh, you mean my ghost tricks?
Apparently they're the power to manipulate inanimate
objects.
So they're ghost tricks.
Oh, sorry.
If they're ghost tricks.
If they're ghost tricks, then can I do them too?
I'm dead too after all.
I guess?
That's how it goes.
No, remember the The lamp said we're special.
I've been staring at those donuts as hard as I could for a
long time now.
But they won't budge for me.
Why do you suppose that is?
I don't really know.
I guess you just don't have that power.
Well, I have one thing to say to that.
That's not fair!
Sorry, but I guess not everyone who dies gets the power of
the dead.
So what's going to happen to me now?
Nothing, really.
Has been erased?
Oh my gosh.
Can you imagine if I like...
What if I got four minutes to go back and like not be dead?
What if I wasn't a ghost?
What if I wasn't a ghost made?
What if I was just a normal maid?
Wouldn't that be so weird?
Do you guys prefer me dead or...
would you rather me be living and happy and like thriving in
life or would you rather me be a sad sad afterlife ghost the
dead thing kind of suits me
one ghost please
just don't be sad you're so right to take a walk tomorrow.
You'll just go back to being a happy little doggy, living
your everyday life.
See, he's going to go back to being a happy, alive dog.
Not a sad, dead dog.
This is a trick question.
A ghost trick question.
I guess this means goodbye.
But we'll meet again sometime, right?
Yeah, maybe.
If you die again, What you did for me tonight?
I'll never...
I'll never forget it!
I guess we'd better get...
Get it...
We...
We'd better...
We'd better get...
Getting back...
Wait, we'd better...
I guess we'd better be getting back to the present.
Time to see what happens.
Next in our story.
I'm okay.
I hope the dog doesn't bark.
Okay, and now a new present is born.
The little lady is still curled up in a ball and shaking
with fear.
And the little doggy is wagging his tail happily.
So what am I going to do now?
I think I'll watch for a while and see what happens.
I didn't mess up with the ball, though.
But we have the music box.
I have a question.
Does this game only have one way to complete a thing?
A puzzle?
This is like asking your girlfriend...
Wait, this is like your girlfriend asking you, do I look
fat?
Still at the junkyard.
Alright, got it.
I'm on my way.
Oh, yes.
Hmm.
I guess my prey likes to play hide and seek.
that junkyard yet, apparently.
I can't let near-sighted G go beat me out of this one.
I'd better hurry.
Oh, is he leaving?
He's just leaving?
Okay.
Nice.
Lock the door.
Please, lock the door!
What was that all about?
Opened the door with the rifle?
I know, he's so cool.
You saved me, didn't you?
missile i just know you did oh my gosh maybe i shouldn't
answer it answers it anyway okay mochi mochi lynn trick time
uh oh what am i trick timing to a call from lynn hey sounds
serious i wonder oh yeah better go possess that phone and
listen in oh no wait oh i didn't realize i There we go.
And round we go.
And over we...
Oh.
There's the little doggy all curled up on the floor.
Dreaming away the life we worked so hard to get back for.
That's fine.
But what's up with that core?
Phone works again.
Mysterious.
Yeah, said like we couldn't use the phone in the four
minutes.
The dead can't possess living creatures.
That's one of the rules Mr. Desclamp taught me.
Say his name.
It's Ray!
So what would a living and breathing doggy be doing with a
core?
I'd better try possessing him and see.
I'm obsessed with possessing.
It's you!
It's, um, come to think of it.
I never did ask your name.
I guess it's good we ran into each other again then.
This music is so happy.
this is a good chance for us to reintroduce ourselves to
each other you mean you forgot my name already after
everything we shared together the drama that tearful goodbye
I'm missile and I'm mental but you know it's strange I
wonder why you remember me that now that you're alive again
do you remember your time being dead of course all of it
okay let me get this straight the memory of being dead And
the dead I meet in the ghost world develop a core when they
return to the land of the living.
Then if I possess that core, I can talk to that person.
Intra- I have to remember that I died?
Okay.
It's a little traumatic, isn't it?
Poor, poor Missile.
There's not a thought behind that eyes, but every day he
just sees himself staring down the barrel, directly at his
face.
He's just like, I'm traumatized.
It looks that way, yes.
Oh, thank goodness you're okay.
Well, I don't know if I'm okay exactly.
You won't believe what just...
Listen to me.
You've got to get out of there right now.
What about dinner?
I was thinking about spaghetti tonight.
Yeah, spaghetti!
I've been murdered before.
Really?
Me too.
Nah, I'm just kidding.
Nah.
I'm just...
Unless.
I'm eating more.
I won't be going back there for a while and you might be in
danger.
You might be in danger if you stay there too.
but I already was in danger just a little while ago oh wow
Lynn could you like care at all meet me at that restaurant
on chicken kitchen oh sorry the chicken kitchen the chicken
kitchen on dead end drive dead end drive I don't know that's
pretty far just hurry okay oh and one more thing bring the
music box with you okay music box oh we got it I love music
boxes.
Is it a present for me?
I'm sorry, but it doesn't play.
I can't even get the lid open.
Then you can't very well call it a music box.
Then can you?
More like just a box.
Oh, just a box.
Just bring it, okay?
It's kind of big and it's made out of wood.
Okay, I will.
Where is it?
I kind of hid it in that room here.
And oh, well, we already got it.
We sped run it.
What the hell are you?
Oh my god.
Excuse me.
Eek!
Lynn!
Oh no!
Oh my god.
Cliffhanger.
Not again.
Darn.
Now I've dropped the phone in there too.
What did it...
Wouldn't it be corded?
Like, you know, those kinds of old...
It looks really old.
Poor fish.
Right?
The fish just got electrocuted!
How about if we tell her you did it, Missile?
Woof, woof!
I sure hope Lynn's alright.
I'd better get going.
I know right where Dead End Drive is.
But I never saw any music box around here.
Where am I supposed to find it?
Do you know where it is, Missile?
Oh my gosh, Door of the Explorer time.
Do you know where the music box is?
Here, if you know where the music box is.
Where's the music box?
Over there.
Where is the music box?
Under the couch, are you stupid?
That's a ball.
Don't you know your basic shapes?
On the tree?
Good job!
Time to trip!
Oh my gosh, look at she's searching, it's so cute.
Oh no, she missed it!
Wait, how am I supposed to...
Oh, maybe I let this go off and then she'll see it.
She saw it!
Dora for 30 year olds.
This is it, the music box.
It's about to say yippee.
I think, is she me?
I'll leave the remote here.
Good.
But don't you touch it, Missal.
If the TV comes on, you'll start barking.
I'd hate to find you flattened underneath that wall when I
came home.
She looks so genuinely sad about that.
All the stuff that's just in the fish tank.
Stay here and be a good boy.
I'm leaving now, Missal.
I have to go help Lynn.
She's like a sister to me, you know?
You'd be good, my boy.
And no barking.
How many tails does Missal have?
Um.
He's like actual tails.
Still no peace for the little lady.
And the redhead Lynn is facing a new crisis right now as
well.
Can your next dream be a key, Julie?
jingling stream
meanwhile I'm a bit of a in a pickle of my own with the
receiver at the bottom of this of the fish tank I find
myself still trapped in this apartment too bad I can't just
curl up and go to sleep with my tail wagging too because
there is something I must do question is how do I go about
getting out of here
do you guys do you guys need me to jingle keys for to uh pay
attention yay 7 31 to 804 new song welcome to the salon nice
yes please
the patchy saw is probably the most key jingling jingle core
stream you've done so far it was like my second stream
Sorry, I wasn't paying attention.
Oh, what was I saying?
Oh no, maybe I need the keys more than you got.
I need them too.
Oh no, we're stuck in a loop of people who don't pay
attention and don't know what's going on.
Once again, Lynn is in danger.
And I think she knows it too.
I sincerely doubt she'll be coming back to this apartment
tonight.
She and I are connected to each other somehow.
She's my only lead and I can't lose her.
I have to get to her.
And fast.
You jingle the keys for us.
We jingle the keys for you.
Nice!
I'm paying attention.
I see all the keys in chat.
Okay, I'm paying attention.
Maybe I get the remote.
Hey, doggy.
Oof, oof, oof, oof!
If she does knock the wall down, then we'll be able to use
her phone.
See?
Oh my god, wait, she's actually going to knock it down.
If you keep that racket up, I'll bring this whole
dilapidated building down on you.
Dingling, ling, ling, ling.
Keep barking, missile!
Did you hear what I just heard?
You mean the lady next door is angry?
No, forget that.
Tomoe!
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
It was the sound of a telephone ringing coming from the
apartment next door.
Oh, I get it.
You're thinking about borrowing her telephone, aren't you?
Saying it with that voice is a little funny.
But how are you going to do that without breaking the wall
down?
Well, the lady next door is kindly offering to do it for us.
So...
Yes, but she's mostly hoping to crush me underneath it.
Um, just keep, keep, keep doing it.
Oh, oh no, I didn't mean to make it go faster.
Uh, slow down a little.
Slow, just calm down.
Wyvern Dragon.
Wyvern Drag.
Welcome to Memorandum Fellowship.
Thank you.
Oh, we're so close.
Can I rock?
Oh, it doesn't rock.
rock enough.
I was thinking like it'll rock side to side and I could like
rock it over here.
There's also up here but I don't think there's anything I
can get in there.
Hmm.
I'd rather not.
Thanks for the vibe gifted.
Thank you.
Um ma ma ma ma.
Talk to him.
Come on now.
Can't you bark any louder than that?
Louder!
But then that lady will knock the wall down on of me we'll
worry about that when it happens oh gosh anyway like i i
don't like you who's gonna pay for that ghost trick is one
of my faves hope you enjoy it and play it all the way
through i will thanks sneaksin we need to have this little
doggy put some more energy into it let's see wasn't there
something else around here that gets a reaction out of him
uh the star
So we do the star and the show.
Oh, there we go.
Oh my god.
I'll pound this.
Holy cow.
Whoa!
Did she just knock the dog unconscious?
I told you, didn't I?
I told you I would knock the wall down on you.
Oh!
He's okay, right?
He's okay, right, dog?
Oh, so this is what it feels like to have a wall knocked
down on you, huh?
It's more like she knocked you out through the wall, really.
Oh my gosh, Tomoy!
Thank you for the besting gift, and thank you!
I'm still alive, aren't I?
Yes?
You are.
But the TV and the Star Ornament aren't.
I'll never bark again not as long as I live but wait a
minute it looks like here one second I'm gonna actually make
this a bit smaller just so it's not so in the way sorry guys
I'm still trying to figure out how to when there's so many
gifted memberships oh my gosh so boy thank you for another
50 when there's so many memberships it kind of like it kind
of like keeps them popping up for so long so the
notification so I'm so sorry But thank you so much!
Thank you!
Thank you so much.
It looks like all that commotion wasn't for not.
Huh?
Ooh, your barking made her create a path for me!
It did?
But the wall is still standing just like before!
But there are paths only the dead can see.
Oh, those kinds of paths!
There we go.
Nice.
Easy peasy.
Bye, Missile!
Oh, so you're leaving, huh?
I guess so.
You're going to go save Miss Camilla and Miss Lynn?
I have to follow my own mystery first and foremost.
That means everything to me.
But you will save them, right?
If it helps me along the way, then yes.
I don't have any powers of the dead.
I'm not even dead, actually.
But I'm going to find a way to go help Miss Camilla too.
We create our own paths, right, Missa?
That's right.
Okay, I'm leaving now.
Guess this is our second goodbye.
It is, isn't it?
My name is Cicel.
If we ever meet again, that's what you can call me.
Cicel, huh?
Got it.
You know what, Cicel?
I'm going to create my own path.
Just like you said.
It goes to sleep.
Oh!
Missile?
Missile!
Missile, please!
You're gonna get a conco...
Can dogs get concussions?
Tonight is that holiest of all nights.
All I need to get some inspiration from the muses is this
bottle and some cheese Here it's to the boorish people next
door.
Oh Nice we're inside this lady's house.
Oh my god, there's a mouse Who's sneezing?
Her hair is it like a tulip?
This is sexy music.
Are you all right my darling angel?
Have you taken your medicine like a good girl?
Oh,
she's got that gamer posture.
She's perfect.
Here I am in yet another strange room.
What's with the oddly tense air of this place anyway?
Now, where is that little treasure I'm looking for?
Who's in the bed?
There it is.
The telephone.
I can just borrow it.
Who's in the bed, though?
I'm so curious.
Let's see.
We got this.
Oh, I can't reach that, can I?
Oh, we can.
I'm just gonna...
We're just gonna let that go through.
And we're just gonna poke you a little bit.
And we're just gonna scooch you a little bit.
I don't know why I'm doing all of this.
oh
my god look at her go wait what is she saying oh mr prime
minister you mustn't i'm a married woman and i'm a married
man but we cannot resist this any longer i'm ready to
abdicate up abdicate it all for you she's writing fan
fiction even if it means my mean, ruination.
Hmm.
Ruination.
Is that even a word?
And that abdicate just doesn't look right somehow.
This is going to nag me all night, I'm sure.
Oh my god.
Philosophie!
Thanks for the five gifted.
Um, boom, boom.
Examine?
Where is that dictionary?
This thing is too heavy.
I can't manipulate it.
Maybe that woman did.
built up her destructive power by hefting this puppy.
It's more like a weapon than a book.
Let's see.
I know I put it here somewhere.
Now where could it have gone to?
I'll...
Trick!
I still...
It's too heavy.
Uh...
I just can't find it.
Wait, the mouse is back!
Um, how do I time this?
Hmm.
Oh, no, I mustn't.
I mustn't allow myself to believe in your love, Mr. Prime
Minister.
But why...
Wait, is that...
Is this him speaking?
But why won't you believe in me?
My love for you is true.
I swear.
And it's so strong.
It overwhelms me.
Rah!
You know, I've always wondered.
If you can be overwhelmed by something, can you be just
plain...
This is going to...
Okay, hold on.
Okay, we gotta get the mouse down there, alright?
Oh wait, I can't reach it!
Oh no!
Wait, oh, here, from here.
Boink!
Is she gonna notice the mouse here?
Oh!
Oh my god.
Oh, I missed it!
Okay, wait, I have to get him down there.
I get it now, I get it.
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
I get it now.
I get it.
Let's wait here.
Because he lands by the book.
Mint.
I'm sorry!
I'm sorry.
Okay.
But I kind of also want to hear this.
No.
Mr. Prime Minister, we mustn't.
If the people ever found out.
I don't care what they might think.
What do the plebeian masses understand anyway?
Certainly not, I love.
Hmm.
What is the Prime Minister talking about?
I don't know.
It's your book!
I've never even heard the word plebeian before.
What is it?
AI writing it for you?
And you're just, like, taking it?
She doesn't even know!
Okay.
Oh, wait.
Tilt.
Beep.
Uh, boop, boop, spin, pew!
And now she'll find it.
No, what?
She didn't find it.
I like watching her typos, like really.
Oh no, we've read it, okay.
Uh, did I do it too soon?
Okay, I have to go through it again though.
Okay, all right.
Psew!
Maybe she- Okay, wait a second.
Maybe she has to see the rat, and then I knock it onto the
floor.
Right?
Maybe she sees the rat first.
There we go.
Oh, there it is.
Let's not care about the rat anymore.
Yippee!
But it's strange.
I know I left this dictionary on the shelf.
It's as if some little angel were playing nightly.
naughty tricks on me I cannot get her accent oh she's like
sometimes southern sometimes British perhaps my darling
angel okay possess
British good choo mama turn
the knob so
where else do I go for oh my god she's so cute oh she's so
cute she looks like uh the other girl from re-zero it is
common for writers to lose their plot to the characters they
just steal the plot we had planned and change it we are
weird like that no snake we mustn't if otakon ever finds out
said Ocelot?
I don't care.
What does that Otaku?
No!
Wrong snake!
Oh yeah, Beatrice!
Beatrice, Beatrice.
What is it, my darling angel?
Ow, my head hurts, mama.
You poor dear, and no wonder with a fever of 102.
Here's to a night of wait, a night of fever.
Hotter than the love of my prime minister.
Oh!
It's almost time for me to... Wait, time to go out.
For my lesson, can I take the night off?
Yes, I suppose that would be best.
But wait a minute.
I bet you're happy to have an excuse to get out of it,
aren't you?
Not especially.
If I ever don't want to go, I just don't go and pretend I
did.
Don't reveal your secrets, Beatrice.
I go play with Camilla next door or something.
my darling angel oh hey today is papa's birthday oh is it
don't tell her yeah what are you doing aren't we going to
celebrate together let's not talk about your father dear oh
dang what's this family drama now mama has to go back to
work i have a deadline tonight after all okay mama wait
I just have one thing to say.
Don't try and put me in the middle of you two.
Okay?
Whatever could you be talking about?
I know what's going on, you know.
You write novels and Papa wants you to stop.
But it was very selfish of you to take me and leave the
house.
What is going on?
I want to go home.
Uh...
Now, now, it's time for good little girls to go to sleep.
Especially sick little girls.
Sleeps.
I hate you, mama!
Dang.
Oh!
What is going on?
Oh yeah, we haven't checked the...
What's it called?
Oh wait.
Uh, this one.
Z-L.
We haven't checked the...
This in a while.
She's still sitting there in the rain.
Hunter in the dog.
Eyebrowed villain.
Masked muscle man.
The other hitman.
The little lady.
I love it.
Valiant pet.
Perfumed lady.
Apparently she's a novelist who moved here agreement with
her husband.
Feverish firecracker.
Apparently she and Camilla are friends.
She isn't going out for her lesson tonight.
Aww, look at her, she's so sick, it's so sad.
And then the phone book.
Oh, it's these places, okay.
Cool.
Wait, a music box was hidden in the ceiling.
Mmm.
Big lady.
These two are quite a pair.
The father would have to be a pretty strong man to hold his
own against them.
Sounds like their family circumstances are pretty
complicated.
I wonder if I had a family.
How, when, when do we get to, oh, my lamp is out.
Wait.
Ma'am, what are you about to do with that?
Ma'am?
Ma'am, what are you about to?
What are you about to do with that?
it immediately but i just i was gonna look to see if there
was anything else around but um um wow
she's a keeper is this still too heavy she brought this
dictionary all the way over here don't look at something
look something up you did not just say irregardless
is this all
I can't tell if this is on purpose or not.
Should have read the dictionary.
This is probably on purpose, right?
Here it sits all alone.
Either she forgot what she wanted to look up, or she forgot
she even wanted to look anything up in the first place.
Hmm.
Is irregardless really a word?
Okay.
My darling lady.
Oh, my darling lady.
To think that you were a spy all along.
What?
What are you going to do to me, Mr. Prime Minister?
I will arrest you and make sure you receive the proper
penalty.
You're sentenced to be imprisoned in my cell of love and
punished with my whip of passion!
Ooh, la la!
Oh, Mr. Prime Minister!
Oh, my dear lady!
I would totally listen to an audiobook of this.
I'd hate to live in this Prime Minister's country.
when
that's still too far away for me to reach everything is
still too far I have to do something when we turn the knob
right it's right up your alley it actually is um hmm I
forgot about your harlequin knob hobby is that uh isn't a
harlequin novel like um an actual brand only
thing i can think of doing is turning off the line what is
going on oh she made a typo ah okay got it got it okay we
have to wait for her to make a typo, clearly.
Oh, I just want to watch this again, though.
She has one spicy mama.
She has one hot meatball!
Yeah!
Uh, I guess I'll turn it off again.
Is that... Oh!
Okay, now she makes the typo.
There we go.
Uh-huh.
Pew!
Oh!
Oh, we're so close!
Okay, now we have to wait.
Wait, how do we get her to make another typo?
Um...
Wait.
Uh...
Um...
Oh!
Pew!
There we go.
Oh, wait, I wanted to do the other one, though.
I wanted to do the clock, but that's okay.
Also, Yanwei, I see your don't know.
Love the flower hair lady's voice.
No, I use this as the prime minister.
If you're made mint, does that voice belong to mistress
mint?
Anyway, missile is best dog.
So true.
Who's saying this?
Hello?
Is that you?
Oh.
How many times are you going to make me tell you?
Tonight is that holiest of all nights, my deadline.
Please, I'm begging you, change your mind, and come home to
me.
I think you're the one who needs to change his mind.
Please, put yourself in my position.
You can write your novel just as well from home.
Until you change your mind, your daughter and I won't be
coming home.
Even if that means, forever!
let me talk to Amelie oh her name is Amelie that at least
you can't talk to her she's sick with the fever right now
and I won't have you giving her nightmares I want to talk to
Papa now I don't want to hear your voice anymore tonight
please wait a minute don't try to call again I won't answer
to answer.
I love them.
They're so dramatic.
Wow, we get to go to Trouble...
Yay, Trouble...
Trouble Man's apartment.
Oh, whoops.
I didn't mean to press that.
You voice her so well, Mint.
Thank you.
Oh, we can't even reach her, though.
I'm curious about what up there though oh no okay we just
have to leave then after all i could her be in like a lump
in there
yeah we still can't reach it okay let's leave dialing to
troubled man's office
i'm a one man show i can voice everybody in this game
Oh!
Are you alright, sir?
Oh, oh, I ordered all of you not to come near me.
Ow!
One of my favorite emotes is the dancing lady emo because
her legs are all like kicked up and she's all like, yippee!
And he looked just like the dancing lady emo.
Oh my gosh, it's so good.
I beg your pardon, sir.
I'm sorry I shouldn't have yelled at you like that yes the
dancing lady it's my favorite on Twitter I think she looks
the best on Twitter but look at her she's so yippee but I'd
like to be left alone right now you you make up yes sir whoo
ole oh bother another strange room and another strange
person.
I wish these telephone lines came with nameplates or
something.
Sheesh.
Alright, let's trick around.
Let's see what we got.
Documents, medicine, bottle, water pitcher, flap the flag.
Whoops.
Flap.
No, I still can't reach.
Huh.
Is there anything else in here?
Oh wow!
Whoa, this room is huge!
There's a big old melon!
Oh my god, it must remind him of her!
Aww.
And the door is open.
Uh oh.
What is with these people not leaving their, not locking
their doors?
The contraption to do the fan.
Anything up in the ceiling?
No.
Don't say melon.
You need to leave!
Oh, my bad.
How am I supposed to...
I still can't reach!
Hmm.
Gonzalo!
That feels like as far as I can get.
Probably involves the fan, which means there's another way
to get to it, but I've...
There's nothing else that I can...
Possess.
Thanks, Enve!
I mean, nothing that I can, like, possess and do something
with, you know.
Maybe...
Maybe I can't do anything yet.
Maybe I have to wait.
Wait, can I...
If I go back to this lady's apartment...
What if I go back to the junkyard?
Is she still there?
No, she said she was going to the restaurant, right?
Vizit Missal, I miss him.
Me, you, you, thank you!
I love you so much!
Thank you!
Not much time has passed since I was here last, but the
situation has changed.
Whoa!
Who are these?
Looks like they're examining my body.
I wonder who they are.
Oh my gosh.
Phoenix pre-spike.
And the other... Oh my god.
Dancing Pixar.
Besides them, a certain somebody else wriggles and bounces
happily.
I wonder who that person really is too.
It's Feeny.
Welcome back.
You weren't gone very long.
What's going on here?
The police are here to start the criminal investigation.
You know, into your murder.
The guy in the green suit looks like the other prosecutor.
Um, the really wimpy guy who always gets his hair blown off.
John attorney name Ace.
Yeah.
You know, into your murder?
My murder case, eh?
Where is Lynn?
Is she alright?
So you found out her name already, did you?
I'm impressed.
Excuse me!
Mad scientist.
It sounded like she was in some sort of, some kind of
immediate danger.
Where's Gumshoe?
So true, I missed that guy.
Mr. Payne!
Yes, that's the other attorney yet, or sorry, prosecutor.
Yes, yes.
Not to mention the fact a hitman is after her again.
I'm eating again.
I am once again taking a bite of chicken.
Oh, um...
Mmm.
You don't have to worry about that kind of thing.
What?
She was just taken into custody a few minutes ago?
Custody?
You mean she was arrested?
But why?
I feel bad because your chicken is probably cold by now.
It is, but that's okay.
I'll eat anything.
I'm a hungry ghost.
I don't know.
I'm just a desk lamp.
Shut up!
No, you're not!
I'd better see what I can find out.
Trick time.
Doesn't he look like pain?
Traffical.
Ultra.
My body.
Cicel.
Bag.
What do you say in here?
Quite a thing, huh?
This case.
Yes!
One of our own.
A murderer.
Heads will rule over this.
One of our own.
Starting my first ever job next week.
So excited.
Your streams have kept me motivated these past few weeks.
So thank you so much.
Touch-talking!
Congratulations!
Congrats!
I hope you have fun.
Fake Phoenix and fake Payne.
She's a rookie too.
Wait, so she's with them.
Oh, I heard she was carrying out some crazy investigation.
diamonds like that not even rookies like lynn i can't oh god
i can't do it
yeah but i heard she was special she's got strong ties to
inspector cabanella of the special investigation unit i plan
on moving up the ladder on my own merits myself okay what
just jealous you it's because the chicken i'm eating has
like a tiny bit of spice and so when i like use my throat
like in that way um my i uh i what's the word i like get the
spice all in my throat also i just noticed that the doctor
is blue i think he's not on our side i think he's with the
bad guys
Or he's a zombie.
I don't know.
Wait, detectives shouldn't be standing around gossiping.
Never know who might be listening.
Like me.
Ah!
Oh, God.
He looks like a zombie for real.
What?
I think we can safely assume the cause of death was the
bullet he took in the chest.
bring the stretcher I'll look into the rest back at the lab
he's so he looks so scary
would you mind waiting here for a bit doctor inspector
Cabanella head of the special investigation unit is on his
way now they have to say his full title Dr. Luigi if it has
spice why don't you just dunk the chicken in milk so true
Thanks for the secret chat.
Special investigation unit.
What do they want with a case like this?
It's alright.
He has a big mustache, so he's probably got a refined voice.
I don't know.
But Cabanella is our top investigator.
We don't want him...
Want to get him all bent out of shape.
Or there will be hell to pay.
Hmm.
I don't see what that has to do with me.
So true, Doctor.
what Cabanella wants to come for either.
It's probably just a big lark for him, but it makes things
tougher on us.
Hey, watch what you say behind his back.
Never know who might be listening.
Like me.
And me.
Is that him?
Whoa, he's...
Oh.
He's kind of awesome.
Wow!
Ah, the tension of a crime scene.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, yeah, nothing like it, baby.
Yo, he's Elvis.
Oh, my God.
Whoa.
He's so smooth, boss.
Oh, wow.
Whoa.
Yo.
Oh.
Evening, boys.
How's it looking?
Inspector Cabanella, thank you for coming.
Allow me to report, sir.
Fine, fine.
You just gotta hold that thought.
I'm gonna make a little phone call first.
I was gonna...
Oh my god, I stopped.
I was literally about to say I'm surprised he didn't spin
around when picking up the phone first, but he didn't pick
up the phone and spy the afterwards.
So this is the head of the Special Investigation Unit.
unique.
Trick time.
Alright, let's... Who is he talking to?
Look at them.
Here he is for his big lark.
Aren't you going to confront him about it?
About what?
I'm going to make my report.
Yeah, that's about what I figured.
You have no spine.
whoa deal me the deal how's it going over there baby going
how is it going you ask you'd like to know how it's going i
would say it's going well enough about fair to average if i
had to say yes It's going all right.
The star child?
Not the man I was hoping to talk to there, baby.
Do me a favor and put that other nice man on the horn now,
would you?
That's a nice fellow.
If it had anything to do with this park, I'm the one to talk
to.
I'm the guardian of this park.
Yes!
Who is this?
They do kind of look like Lottie.
Oh, get out of here.
Oh.
Sorry about that, Inspector.
I just got here.
Well, glad to hear you made it.
That other fellow just about threw me for a loop.
Yeah, a lot of heart.
Yeah, yeah.
Start blathering, something about being the guardian of the
park or something such.
Yes, him.
Sorry about that.
We'll start doing your staking out.
thing baby then buzz me if anything comes up yes sir yes sir
trace complete we're going to the park park
now then sir if i make my if i if i if i make me make me if
i if i if i make my report sir
talking to me i need you to handle this case with your
finest care and attention would you do that for me dog that
guy stutters a lot yeah he does i'm what a loser with a
stutter don't need you to tell me how to do my job i like
the doctor anywho i'd like to see the suspect now if i may
be taken into custody voluntarily sir she's being detained
in the junkyard superintendent's office right now super off
super is office a super and where's that yeah what a loser
yeah wait just stop stuttering bozo just beyond where you
parked your bicycle inspector where Oh, they lowered the
drawbridge.
I'll go interview the suspect then.
Yeah, nothing like it, baby.
Wait, I need to go follow him.
Oh, oh.
Carry on, boys.
Good luck, sir.
Look at him go.
Even up the stairs.
He's so cool.
Oh.
Trick time.
Oh, that Inspector Cabanella.
He sure has a...
a strange error about him.
You could say that again.
And I've never seen anybody use stairs the way he does.
I hear he is dancing his way up the stairs of promotion,
that same airy way.
He's like the Joker.
And I hear Lynn is his personal favorite.
What's the deal between those two?
Hey, how should I know?
How do I get up there anyway?
Traffic sign, traffic code, umbrella.
I guess maybe we go to the park instead.
Right?
Let's check it out.
We live in a society.
It appears to be the entrance to a nearly deserted, dimly
lit park.
The voices of two young people drift over to me on the
breeze.
What is going on?
Stop the park from being turned into a housing site.
Protect the park.
The rock of the gods.
Sorry, but could you do that somewhere else?
I'm a little busy right now.
I don't have time to talk.
I suppose you think I'm a man of dubious character.
A questionable person.
No, I, uh...
But if an objective person were asked, they might think you
were a little suspicious yourself so true how does he get
his hair like that as two suspicious characters shouldn't we
take the time to converse with each other it's one way to
put it pal yeah oh boy all right just for a minute hope you
have a great stream today men just came home welcome home
welcome home nine thank you there i like your attitude i
like it very much let's relax and talk a while then the
knight is young and so are we oh man
is he flirting or i don't really know we have this leaflet
oh we can't literally go anywhere else oh no
back to the junkyard, I suppose.
Couple dead ends, yeah.
I was trying to get tired too, so might end soon-ish.
I wanted to end if we, like, saved one more person because
it kind of, like, gave us that save, but...
Oh, what's a dog saying?
Oh!
I think we can safely, pretty safely assume that this was
the murder weapon.
Oh, they found the murder weapon!
Can you not use the lamp?
It's not moving.
Oh, no, that pistol.
Is it hers?
Is it Lin's?
Same model as the pistols you detectives carry around.
Ooh!
You don't think it's Lin's, do you?
Unless I'm a detective.
No, I'm Lupon.
Lupon's cousin.
This is not good.
If it is hers, it's Jover.
weapon might be her pistol.
What could it all mean?
Trick time.
Yeah, see, I can't reach the lamp, and it's not moving
anymore.
This is the weapon that took my life.
A pistol, eh?
My memory seems to be hazy on pistols.
But I have seen them before, that's for sure.
Let's see.
This part right here is...
Oh!
Fool!
If you want to fire the thing, aim it in your own direction.
Lupine the 3.5.
Grupa in the 3rd.
I didn't fire it.
I'm the victim here.
This is the act of somebody who's jealous of my abilities as
a detective.
What are you glaring at me for?
I'm hardly jealous of you.
Well, guess that proves it's a real gun.
Sheesh.
What was that?
Is that what I think it was?
The sound of a gun.
I've got a bad feeling about this.
Every time that phone rings, it's bad news.
It's like that old riddle.
Which came first?
The ringing of the phone?
Or the crime case?
Classic.
Classic saying.
If you say so.
Uh-oh.
doctors like anyway that was that sounded bad um anyway oh
there you are do me a favor and have the doc come to you to
do the super super his office would you uh he seems pretty
busy at the moment sir which one of you which one are you
the green one or the blue one oh i'm the the green one sir
listen greeny get the good doc over here this instant or
i'll see it you never wear a green suit again you'll only be
wearing black and white stripes in the slammer yes sir i'll
send him up right sir we're
going to the super's office here he goes please doctor go to
the superintendent's office immediately.
If I must.
There he goes.
Shuffling away.
No one cares about my body.
What's going on?
Don't ask me, but something seems really, really wrong.
That shot sounded like it was coming from somewhere around
the maintenance building.
Okay.
Oh.
Uh, dial.
To the super's office.
Who died?
Oh my god, wait.
There might be someone that actually died.
Yet another gunshot rings out in the lonely junkyard on the
edge of town.
The sound gives me the feeling a new death will be waiting
on the other side of the line.
It better not be her again.
Apparently, I'm not the only one the Reaper is interested in
tonight.
But as long as there's anything I can do about it, I don't
plan on letting anyone else die.
Is it Lynn?
I hope not.
Lynn.
were you alive are you good oh we cleared it nice um what a
funny illustration it's just it's just the lamp riko thanks
for the 20 gifted thank you yes okay good we got the save i
am kind of curious to see though who died so we'll see and
then i'll end it here chapter four how many chapters are
there actually i have no idea changing a person's fate is no
easy task especially when their fate is death the scene at
the other end of the line is pretty much what i expected all
except for one thing
oh that is her no no hang in there baby what it looks like
some piece of trash shot her from the top of the pile of
garbage outside!
Here, let me take a look at her.
Maybe there's something I...
Sorry, can't allow that, Pigeon, ma'am.
I investigate, and you super intend.
You have your job, and I have my...
I feel like they keep killing off Lynn so that we can't get
more information out of her.
So that more things are mysterious.
She seems like the type that would, like, info dump, you
know?
And, like, kind of explain things to us out loud.
Let's leave each other to his own profession, shall we?
Yeah, well, here's what I think.
How much of a pro can you be if you let her get shot right
in front of you?
Anyway, have it your way.
I'll stay out of your hair.
We got the mad scientist with his little pigeon.
So cute.
Oh!
Where did the bird drop it?
So cute!
Burn!
What?
He's so awesome!
That was so smooth!
That's not how...
Okay.
Everything's so goofy.
What took you so long?
Quit dragging your feet.
Who are you to shout at me?
Now let me have a look at the victim.
I haven't even looked yet, but I can already tell you she's
dead.
Her second death of the night, actually.
Yo, it's like final destination.
You're fated to die.
Yeah, I'm getting kind of eepy.
We are going to stop here.
So I'm going to save.
Oh, oops.
Nope.
There we go.
I'm going to save.
Yes.
And we shall continue this next time.
Sometime next week.
week yes yes yes sounds good uh continue playing no i'm
sleeping oh 15 chapters last so 20 what 20 chapters i know
that i said like how long to beat said about uh 20 hours oh
not 20 sorry 12 hours um but with like reading and talking
and everything you can kind of extend that a little bit
longer maybe um but we'll see
18 18 hours or 18 chapters
weird logarithm thank you for the vibe get it thank you
thank you but uh it's a ride i'm excited 12 hours sounds
canon there's 14 left so there's still a long run yeah i'm
excited i'm already so invested thanks for the stream this
is one of my favorite games it's so cool seeing play it yeah
i wanted i've been wanting to play it a really long time and
uh my friend she recommended it so i was like well i mean
i'm a ghost so now's the perfect time to play it favorite
character so far missile i like missile i like actually the
the fan fiction lady too but uh today's my birthday but the
only thing i got gifted was a written exam.
I'm going to ask her a happy birthday.
Of course, TripTrip!
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear TripTrip.
Happy birthday!
Missle cute Missle so cute Thanks for the stream I used to
some great voices It was fun to listen to While I worked I
tried to Because like What if you're not looking And you're
like Who's talking You know I saw people finishing Four to
five streams Okay That's totally doable then It's totally
doable I'm gonna I'm gonna try and finish before Because um
In the next Upcoming weeks I'm gonna be Going out of town Um
Oh well No I keep thinking I'm going out of town For one
weekend but i'm not but i am going out of town and then
before i know it i'll be going to japan so so much going on
already oh but tomorrow i'll be collabing with um haruka
matara and henya again we're playing left for dead oh i
gotta i gotta get some i gotta get some of the some of the
models and stuff i gotta get some of the models the download
stuff.
Yeah, get the mods.
Yeah!
Wowza!
I ghost tricked back in time to send this!
Thanks, Rongo Rabbit!
This game is a legendary puzzle game.
Might consider picking it up again while it's on sale, too.
Thanks for the stream, Mint.
Yeah!
I got it on sale, actually, for the Switch.
It is on sale.
It was like $10 off, so it was really awesome.
I was like, Yahoo!
Yippie!
I tried calling you on my Ouija board, but all it said
was...
Ronesaker.
What is that?
Turns out I accidentally used my Norwegian board instead.
Classic mistake, honestly.
Never seen this play game before, but man, it's so fun.
Can't wait to see where this goes.
Thanks, AKS!
Thank you.
Vegetables?
It means vegetables.
Eat your...
Grandsakers, everybody.
Collapse's going to be so much fun.
Yeah, I'm so excited.
So, yes.
Thank you guys for hanging out with me today.
Thank you so much.
Merlin, thank you.
Thanks for the ghostly tricky stream.
Just curious, since you're a ghost, if you have any famous
ghost role models like Casper, Beetlejuice, Yu-Gi-Oh-ji, to
be fair, Ace Combat 7, that was also on sale.
I think a lot of games are on sale, right now because of
Golden Week.
So might wanna grab some stuff, Japanese games in
particular, you know?
I really enjoyed this stream today.
Thanks, Ash!
Thank you!
Sorry, is it okay if I shorten your name to that or should I
keep saying the full name, you know?
Oh.
Yeah.
At least go on Mike.
I feel like I was gonna say something else but I can't
remember oh tomorrow I have but yeah tomorrow I have the
collab and then Saturday I have a what I'm part of a a
karaoke relay with a bunch of other VTubers so the waiting
rooms for both streams are already up so yes yes if you're
hearing about you wanting to be a marine biologist and
liking sea conservation from the podcast I want to Aquatope
on white sand.
I've seen Aquatope!
I've seen Aquatope and actually the opening is done by my
one of my favorite idol groups, Arcana Project.
Yeah, I didn't think I'd be able to continue my membership.
Oh, thanks, Shady Raven.
Thank you.
Appreciate it.
Japanese games on sale, but no Nekopara on sales.
Dusko!
Hi, man.
I got my wisdom teeth taken out this morning and after I
woke up, I just rambled on about how much I love you.
I know!
I got a video of it.
Thank you.
I love you too.
That's so strong.
That's so awesome.
It's all on video.
I watched it like three times.
Your voiceover work for the characters was out so on point.
It was a ton of fun watching you play.
so much.
I love doing voices and games like this.
But it does make me tired out a little bit more.
But I do, I've been taking a lot of, um, a lot of throat
medicine, um, lately.
And I do feel like my throat has been, uh, healing.
So I'm very, very relieved.
I'm very happy about that.
But I, I take it like three times a day.
It's like a Chinese herbal medicine thing.
So that a lot of, um, I, first, uh, actually it was Ayami
Sensei that gifted it to me and um uh so i tried it uh when
she gifted it to me first and then i ordered some more so
yeah i'm so i'm so relieved three times a day so much i i i
take it i take it in the morning and then i take it before
stream and then i take it after stream so um is it paypal
cow yes yes yes yes koa it is that it's so great it works so
well boy boy cute you're so cute oh my gosh but yeah it's
super duper it is the good stuff it seriously works so well
um we love ayami i know i love her so much but um it's
actually really delicious it is it's delicious and it works
they have bubble tea flavors with it in Asia seriously it's
very reliable you can even make it a tea yeah I have seen
that but I just take it by the spoonful but um it has been
helping so much so I'm very very grateful that she
introduced it to me she's going to Chicago I know I'm so
happy for her I think it's her first time going to a
convention so in Singapore we got the bubble team with
really maybe i can import it maybe but yeah anyways um so
i'm feeling i'm feeling good about that because i was like
so worried about my throat for a while um but it's been
helping
you're so close to 200k i know wait where what am i at i
don't even know i think i'm still at oh wait last yeah i was
at one 190 197
197 we'll see we'll see we'll see so close woohoo anyways on
sumito everybody I'm gonna go sleep now I'm actually gonna
finish my dinner and then I'm going to sleep.
And I'll see you guys tomorrow for the collab and Saturday
for karaoke and Sunday.
And I don't think I'm streaming one day.
I don't think I'm streaming one day.
I'll actually have a schedule for next week since it's...
Oh wait.
When is Matara coming?
No, wait.
Actually, I don't think Matara is coming anymore.
I don't know.
I'm going to ask her.
Anyway.
bye bye bye thank you guys we'll play more ghost trick um a
couple days yeah yeah next week next week i might even do
like a couple ghost tricks in a row or something because i'm
having a lot of fun with it so but i do kind of need to rest
my voice because it's a lot of talking and we'll figure it
out okay bye bye bye have a good night have a good night or
if it's morning have a good day What's up mentors?
Bye bye bye What's up mentors?
Thank you!
Bye bye